car Nakamura here again I've been been
away for a little bit but I'm back now
I'm going to place a knock out so let's
let's see let's see who's online to
start with okay looks like everyone's
playing at the start okay I'll just
start by playing some random people and
just just to get just to get the flow of
everything going so yeah alright so I'm
playing this artificial selection guy
maybe maybe not let's see so okay so I
played efore also see what he's gonna do
unfortunate looks like he's not here so
I'm gonna birth that all right let's see
so I see some guys in like the low
twenty five hundreds who are on that's
not overly exciting I'm gonna wait to
see if one of these top guys finishes
like daro or Dimitri want one of these
that guys are Yakov maybe if he's if
he's around as well
Ibrahim writes naka looking rough ah
maybe my hair's a little bit out of it
I've been a bit busy I was asleep a
little bit earlier so I just woke up so
yeah let's see okay so I'll play okay so
I'll play it south on Gabriel Cardos
scarf Cardoso look so he's from
Venezuela guys want to play E for g6 d4
Knight c3 d5 I'll just play e5 you can
take with the pawn taking with the
Knights not best cuz I'm block would
play c6 1 upon on d4 I'm going to c5
I'll take and I will I will try to pay
attention to those of you here in the
here in the chat when I when I have the
chance east 6 I'll play out 497 play be
for a night be thought action 95 looks
pretty pretty strong I'm giving I'm
gonna get back to palm and I'm gonna get
a check then he's going to move his King
off of f8 so let's let's see if he takes
the pawn probably he will he doesn't
okay
Knight h6 I'll check King f8 I'll play
b4
protect this extra pawn here on c5 if a5
I'll place c3 so let's see okay so what
do you just do we just took on e5 so now
if I take Queen h4 g3 Queen B for this
looks a little bit wrong okay he's gonna
get the pawn on b4 but do I want to make
this interesting or do I just want to
win this cleanly I guess is the first
question so I can play Queen d2 Queen h6
maybe I'll play Queen d2 just to see so
Queen c5 I could take the knight if I
really want to be adventurous I it
doesn't really seem right so I'm just
gonna play a four with the idea of
putting the bishop on a3 putting
pressure along this diagonal so both her
rights he car is that an
industrial-sized fan in your room no
it's not it's just it's just a standard
fan bring it over just a standard for
NATO fan for those of you who are
wondering so it just happens to blow my
hair a little bit okay so a for plays d4
play Knight f3 Bishop e3 and I three
protect the pawn here on e5 and it's
night on h6 is really misplaced now it's
gonna be hard to ever like win this a
five pawn without losing the night here
on h6 so so King g8 um play Knight e4
could take I could play 98 maybe I'll
just play 94 just play good good good
standard moves on someone said going to
the microphone is the mic refugee me
very well let me let me know I'll turn
off the volume so Queen d5 played with
d3 complete we know for a lot of
attractive moves
I like Queen out for just to protect
upon it a5 and also stop Knight g4
okay so I just moved the family about a
little bit more out of the way on if
it's still too much I can probably just
turn it off or something unfortunately I
don't have a fan here but um yeah okay
I'll just move it down oh okay so yeah
okay what are you just do me play a
night of five play g4g fort worth's a
night going doesn't look like it has any
squares I'm just gonna play it 93 I was
take I'll play worked d1 threatened rook
da Chuck is gonna go clean a5 chuckle
place c3 cut him off now I can't develop
this Bishop because the rook is covering
this you know this hold D file and also
his King has rook like it pretty much
all those pieces here it just very very
badly placed so yeah so I will be paying
attention to the to the chat here quite
a bit more at least the Starks I guess
like Eric's not around right now to play
with so Queen c7 play Knight f6 could
just take the pawn on e3 play g5 I mean
I can pretty much do anything here it's
just a question what makes the most
sighs now I am up on time I'm not up
like an insane amount of time but I
think I'll just play Bishop b5 here
stop Bishop e7 he'll probably play a 6
I'm gonna go bish be a tri-attack this
pawn here on a f7 since it is one of the
big weaknesses here on the position for
block so King f8 oh if I Castle I give
him eat or something fine I'll just play
Knight d6 we can see three key to
threatening mate on f7 I'll just take
the pawn of Queen b6 or queen c3 let's
play King you two back he's kind of okay
so f5 I mean that's some it's a move
I'll just take he takes g5 and it's
pretty much over
so e5 just takes a 7
okay so that's a good start good start
with a win okay so second game d4 what
do you guys want me to play what should
my first move be I'll let you guys say
in the chat what you want my first move
to be here and I'll play it so for first
first flight people who say I move all
I'll pick whichever one is the you know
best of the slide
okay so c5 d5 c5 grünfeld a6 a7 okay I'm
gonna play c5 even though I much
preferred against efore as opposed to d4
I'll just play c5 and Cardosa writes
master again I don't think you realize
that I'm streaming so I was asking you
guys what my person was gonna be so a
six this is an old Indian set up play
Bishop e7 basically this pawn structure
you want to get the bishop outside the
deck diagonal or not diagonal sorry you
want to get outside the pawn chain here
if you can so there should be two all
this take I'm gonna play Bishop g5
probably exchanged R squared bishops
I'll take up lychee six probably h4 h5
fixed pawn structure now although now
his bishop is behind his pawns so there
are some advantages for me here so
Knight f6 basically why I will also want
to see which way is gonna Castle
probable Castle short not certain but I
assume so can I do one
I'll go King g7 oh so he plays rook to
one so yeah he actually he wants to try
and attack me which it's kind of
ill-advised his King here is in the
center and the only way he's gonna
attack be able to attacks with some kind
of g4 so I'll play rook c8 or not rook
c8 or c4 I'll try to make it interesting
I'll play c4 nice we please be four so
he doesn't want to let me make it
interesting fine I'll force them all in
Sisson place c3 sac another pawn this
sac is probably not good but it's early
in the evening and I feel like taking
some some risk so Bishop d3 you know not
not grabbing the pawn
now I'm gonna probably play for f5 yeah
I'll do it right now in fact f3 I'll
take takes I'll go back
now it has to take now now after rook c8
his pieces are a little bit his pieces
are kind of loose now with these pawns
here like he's gonna have some issues
here in the center at some point I think
I mean if I play badly he'll just be up
a pawn but this this does look pretty
good for me so so 91 I'll take leave
Queen takes I'll play Knight f6 we takes
and I can play Knight f6 and he is
Knight f2 or Queen c7 I'm gonna play
Knight f6 basically he's got you know
this pawn structure that's not really
ideal so night have to I'm gonna play
Queen c7 threaten Queen c3
you know forking the King in the rook
now if he's really bold he'll castle but
even if he doesn't castle c2 is also
hanging here so there are a lot of
weaknesses here for white in this
position so rook c1 no I'm click Queen
c3 Queen d2 now it feels like there
should be something here for me but I'm
not seeing it right off could I maybe I
just take him play Knight d5 or 95 right
away I'll take right away so now he's
gonna take with the pawn I'll trade
trade Queens and then uh then his
Knights gonna hang on f2 at the end I
could have taken trade Queens first none
played 95 but I thought he'd have 93 and
I'd prefer this version of it oh this is
all really really good cuz now his pawns
are just really really bad and this
Knight actually dominates the rook like
the rook can't go to B 1 or D 1 here so
I've got like rook c4 coming as well
like it's just a everything's kind of
hanging here so g4 I'm gonna play King
h6 normally I wouldn't play a move like
this I mean probably I would just play
like takes and kingships there but I
feel like being prophylactic playing
nice smooth positional chest tonight
because now h4 is weakness so you know
so you see I've got c4 now I've also got
f4 so I'm like able to attack all of his
pawns here it's a 93 now I could take
the pawn but I'm gonna play rook c4 just
keep his King on e1 now I'm gonna take
take with the tempo Knight of 6 95 is
coming oh so beautiful so beautiful
Eric f1 I could take the pawn on c2
so I have 95 check so I will take
because I'm holding on to this 95 check
or night you for Chuck and so this pin
doesn't actually mean anything right now
so rook c1 I feel like there's me
meeting to right or mating 3 sorry Chuck
Chuck rookie to Chuck and rookie to
Chuck me
all right so that's two so far so good
all righty 4g64 probably gonna play the
same one maybe he's probably gonna play
d5 no this time he's gonna play d6 I'll
play off for play an offshore intact now
it's interesting he's gonna try and play
like I do but normally I play besets
Bishop d7 and here he hasn't played any
of these moves so should be interesting
to see what he wants to do c5 no it
looks kind of ugly
I take maybe Chuck I think I'm just
gonna chop it should be seven okay so
that's a that's a good move I'm gonna
play e5
there should be five probably was not
the best mode to play so now I'm just
gonna retreat and basically say I gave
you a free Tom fo but it doesn't matter
even though it probably does h4 or not
yeah I'm gonna play it well I'm gonna
try just attack him and just like
basically made him so alright Bishop c6
all aboard h5 just all in go for the
meat why worry Brooke da 22 probably
he'll take please Knight f5 now I could
take the knight I could take on g6 if I
take Knight G 3 so I'll play queen
enough to cover the g3 and D for squares
also g4 might be a threat at some point
now
yes I see chest face trust me I wrote a
column about the world Blitzen rapid
being in Saudi Arabia I do believe
that's not official yet so I'm not gonna
you know I don't have a specific comment
on it but I do think you know it's
certainly not um not ideal but again
I've heard you know I've I've been
following that closely so so I've heard
about it but again I haven't seen it
actually listed on the feed a website so
until I see that you know I don't really
have us you know I don't have a direct
comment on it so G 494 now I'm gonna
just gonna take Queen B for now I could
trade Queens I could play Bishop III
also I'm just gonna play Bishop III and
play for work d1 so now I could play
worth do you wanna I could take first
I'm gonna take first then I'm gonna play
Queen h4 up D which one
rook d1 or Queen h4 it's tricky because
Queen h4 actually Queen h4 looks really
really strong so I'm threatening rook d1
and then the you know it's Queen and
it's rook are under attack he plays
Knight a6 oh man there's got to be some
way to made him here I'm just clean i t4
go for Knight f6 check if I can get it I
mean this has to just be like meeting on
the spot it's hard to believe the block
and can be okay here
so let's see what what he's gonna come
up with so but but yeah you know if the
if the event is held there it's in
December I would say it's very unlikely
that I'm gonna be competing there hang
out 8 ok now I could play 95 96 at 5:00
the move also I mean there's so many
good moves here but you know this is
blitz after all I'm just gonna be
practical and put my King on F to get
get out of any you know any discoveries
or any nonsense like that and and ok so
you play C 3 now I could take I could
take with the pawn I could just play B 3
I mean there's there's so many good
moves here but let's see ok so C 3 I'm
gonna play B 4 I'm gonna do something
unusual
oh the B floor might be a bad move
somebody just giving him like Queen c6
or something very very unnecessary now I
can go King f3
I yeah I've kind of made a made a mess
out of this now I could also play just
play rook T 1 or T 1 or T 1 Queenie 48
yes I do like rook do one now so if he
takes takes place cleaning for them I'm
gonna check made them on da
but I have made a Masai before was just
a very bad like I could have even just
taken with a pawn anything was better
than what I've what I've done in here
but I'm still doing pretty well I would
say so I can take if I want to I can
play Knight f6 if you even just play a3
something really silly I'm just gonna
play a three protect my pawn on b4 cuz
he still has no threats with riff d1 so
now I play the rook to e8 so now I can
take the rook if I want to which I will
actually I'll just take take King e7
work do lungs if he takes and I've
worked d7 checkmate
and in fact I think blacks just lost
here
it's a b6 any threats you believe he
wants to go night c7 probably okay so
I'm gonna play rook d6 Queen c7 and now
f5 should be mate no it's not quite mate
actually I'm getting a long time too so
I have to be careful be 595 I'm just
gonna play out five I'm only gonna be up
a p-series he's gonna take I'm gonna
Chuck he's gonna take well I'm only up a
piece here but this is technically
winning so so I'm gonna have to
basically just blitz him out but of
course this is all completely winning
so yeah I know this is all just winning
of course okay so that's three alright
next game and I have three I'll just
play D six three six play something I
got to be a little bit faster for
watching the chat too much so got way
too long time that game five ninety five
so probably takes e4 on a close - page
three this is probably my favorite
bullet opening I like to play us a lot
it's not not very good but sometimes it
works when you - I'll play h4 probably
takes point you - probably I'll take
I'll take I assume he'll take with pawn
yeah I'll take tonight I'll play queen
g4 yeah I probably has position like a
million times and ball it not so common
in and just blitz but in bullet I've had
is pushing so many times so we've got
three Knight f6 probably he'll take I'm
just gonna castle and go rookie chair I
just want to get this rope over here as
fast as possible and then I'm then
everything's wonderful although after
king f2 he is he wants to play work h1
himself so I'm gonna go clean h5
threatened or cage 2 plays g4 Queen h4
check
and the nick of time asked the million
dollar question how do you feel about
Bitcoin um yeah I've been out of Bitcoin
for a bit now you know I feel like with
many different things it's one of those
vehicles you should use for trading
unless you've been in since very early
on at which point I think there's plenty
of reason just to hold what you have but
um in general I think that if you
weren't in very early it makes much more
sense to basically trade the trade the
highs and lows for example I think it
was at maybe thirty six thirty seven
hundred and then there were some
comments by a Jamie Dimon who's from
JPMorgan Chase the bank then it went
down to like twenty eight hundred and
now it's now it's been on a big run it's
all the way up to I think fifty four
fifty five hundred I haven't looked in
the last day or so but I think in
general it makes sense to to trade it i
I don't I don't like buying at these
levels and holding essentially so if
you're interested in like Bitcoin or any
of the Kryptos for that matter I think
basically treated as something that
you're gonna trade so try and get in you
know when it goes down maybe ten fifteen
twenty percent and then you know on the
upswing solid for a profit so Queen B
five I'll take the pawn king d3 I'm
gonna play B six I don't see a mate
right off I don't see mate at all so I
should be fine here so Queen a six-night
King be a laws work a three so I'm just
gonna go I could go King d8 yaks when he
takes after Queen B eight Chuck kingi
seven he is no on no checks so now I
should have some way to mate and maybe
the Queen H five yeah this looks pretty
good cuz on Queen and eight I go to e7
on Queen B it I go to d7 so he's got no
tracks either way the Queen b8 you know
but but getting back to that topic since
I saw someone said way too late to buy
Bitcoin you know if you turn on
something like CNBC for example you you
will hear them occasionally saying it's
it's really it's really early in the
game the kryptos are just you know they
aren't mean stringing outs or you know
you're in the very earlier innings of
you know
of this technology but I do think it's a
little bit insane to him to buy and hold
at these levels I certainly would not
try to buy and hold anywhere above about
33,000 3,500 max c-46 Knight f3 again if
you guys do have questions keep them
coming I will try to answer them
I'm sure crypto is not what most people
want to talk about they'd rather see me
just play chess but I will try to a
multi task a little bit to Bishop d3 so
he takes I'll just take with the Knight
d6 castles b5 help the Queen c2 probably
he'll play rook e8 nor keet probably
I'll play Eve for I'm not I'm not sure I
mean my knight should be on c3 not t2
here so it's positions a little bit
weird but it's still still the normal
position issue they can't really do that
so but now because he played this other
order of Bishop g4 I think I can go
Knight g5 and on each six maybe Knight
h7 maybe 94 I think I'll just play
Knight h7 he'll take I'll take King h8
Bishop f5 or maybe I have 3 even depends
I think I'll just play off 3
so an entire sleeve rights what's your
favorite variant quickly actually I
think I might be able to play g4 here
I'm just gonna retreat wrote what's my
favorite variant of chess crazy house
etcetera um probably for me yeah crazy
house is my is my is my favorite variant
you know bug house I like a lot but it
is it is to players and and you know the
crazy house getting take off pieces put
them back on and it's very tactical it's
much more suited to what I what I like
so if I if I had to pick one thought
that would be that would be my favorite
so anyway I'm gonna play G for him call
call this guy's Bluff disease he's
basically daring me to play chief for
I'm a little bit confused as to what his
plan is so I play 94 here a four coins
you for doesn't look quite right King H
one team each one a rookie one I think
rookie one might make more sons aged 423
off for Queen g4 yeah I've just got I've
just got to play fast
I'm Way too slow tonight for some reason
so I'll play rook e1 he's gonna go
Bishop g6 I'm gonna take he'll take with
a partner that the Queen either one's
possible and for that reason Ricky won't
probably was wrong because I probably
want my work to go to be one if he takes
with the pawn here so if he takes Queen
take because if you place Queen takes
take 694 I'm probably in good shape if
he takes the pawn I'll play 94
I'll take if he takes for the night I'll
trade and he hangs ji-suk so he's gonna
take with a pawn I'm gonna play d6 make
use of this a strong past D pawn if I
can work d1 protect the pawn this where
Ricky won't probably was just a waste of
a tempo I could have had my King like on
h1 or something but still if this
position is looking quite good for me so
I'll play Age 3
rook c6 I'm just gonna play King Chee to
protect everything make it solid in fact
I could have just played King G - right
away I mean this probably was
unnecessary but anyway I want to play a
four now try to figure out what he's
doing here you know on a queen side with
this pawns
work that seven I'll play King G - don't
play a five fix the pawns so that he can
never play b6 protecting this and now
his Knights kind of stuck um b5 if i
team can i play Knight c5 that seems a
little bit strange
okay I'll take the knight queen c8 right
now d7 is there I don't really want to
play these I'm just gonna play Knight e4
and now if 94 I think I'll play Queen b3
place community for all this play
technical again takes rook d3
use this pass D pawn with this great
night here on e4 c1 probably Knight b6
95 and this is getting pretty bad in a
hurry for block I mean maybe rook you
one was better first I'm not sure but
anyway d7 he's gonna play rook d8 open
it rookie 697 work d1 with the big pin
on the on the rook on D 8 takes I'll
take I'm gonna try to check me in and be
cheeky with Age 4 player and I could
play rook c8
I could play I mean I'll just take the
pawn and there's no need to get fancy
here right five rook D I'm just gonna
double and try to checkmate him here on
h8 if I can okay seven hey five rook d7
takes just take the take the knight so
yeah C resigns
so far so good Knight f3 I'll play I'll
play similar to last well just play the
same thing until he - saw I please be
three I'll move - okay place c5 play d5
knight c6 - night of sex I mean you
could take I'll go Queen a5 plays Bishop
b5 that's a strange move okay so Queen a
five-fold take I would assume well
Castle probably I'm just Castle c4 I'm
gonna play Bishop a6 put pressure on
this diagonal
Quincy to the rock ac8
dc4 or cd4 sorry yeah so someone just
wrote I hear someone recognize you on
the Li Li double are actually was it was
metro-north I was taking the taking the
train from White Plains which is where
my parents live in to N to the city to
Manhattan and and you know this this guy
this dominican guy recognized me was
just getting off work and so yeah when
we're on the train basically opened the
chest automap on on his phone and I
didn't actually play play for him but
you know I did give a few suggestions
and he won like 10 games or something so
he got his rating from things like 1800
and 1900 or something like that okay so
a three might be six probably takes
takes
ninety-two guess he wants to do
something similar and I quickly have
five I mean this is not really what I
wanted out of this opening I should have
had better than this but you can't
always go you want in life I have five
I'll play Bishop hate I guess and of
course all donations are welcome I know
someone someone said something about
that a second ago um that I that I
missed on 94 okay can i take and play
something weird like takes Queen c3
knight c6 Queen b3 Queen five doesn't
quite work Queenie five right away takes
doesn't quite work and if I take take
and basically here I'm just trying to
find a way not to make this a draw
essentially this position is very draw
here so I think I will take I got to be
fast of course I'm not fast and I'm
gonna end up in trouble anyway so
Queenie five maybe Knight c3 maybe Queen
c3 I'm not really sure which one okay so
it's gonna play pin c3 and try to make a
draw essentially as I sort of expected
him to do so I'm gonna have to be fast
I'll probably miss your comments for the
next like three minutes as I'm gonna try
to flag him but otherwise it's all good
to be four Wow
very bold I'm player of ca if he takes I
take and I get a double attack on his
knights
and so actually here I might have to
move his night away that's please rooks
to one but I think now I can take and
play 95 92 I'll trade and all I'll win
the pawn on b4 probably depends if you
go Z 2 maybe I go rook b8 so probably
he'll go to a - now you know what
regardless I'm just gonna trade I'm just
gonna try to pick up the pawn bring my
cane closer I'll play knight c6 try to
exchange a set of Knights Knights c4
I'll play what will I play you're
awfully Bishop d7 hey all right
what is a5 what oh that was just
terrible okay now I really I'm gonna
have to fly and that was just such an
offer cod oversight on my part no draw
no draw
okay King f8 now I want somehow put my
knight I have five if I can how do I do
that
okay now I'm getting somewhere now okay
King g7 and I'm gonna get Knight f5 have
an eye is e4 very lucky so basically
here I'm just gonna finally fly so let's
see if I can now I'm gonna get the
Knight to f5 Uganda's so and now I did
succeed now I'm gonna now I'm gonna win
this
terrible terrible technique just
terrible wow so slow okay that was
pretty awful um anyway okay so far so
good another one it's up to six now a
six I'll play Knight of 3d four cakes
takes 906 Bishop g5 p7 Queen d2 on of
course trying to avoid theory in general
when I play on here so definitely
normally you put the Queen on f3 not d2
but this is you know another setup that
you can kind of try Bishop e7 this is d
395 I'll play Knight f3 h 6 Bishop h4
all right so yeah okay
so yeah what what what else do I miss
anything while you guys are playing or
not playing but while I was while it
sing I don't see any other questions in
the meantime b6 I'll play work to see
one put pressure on the Queen he's gonna
have to move it off the C file goes back
to DA tall castle
she'll be someone I'll play tricky one
or die just hanging any four I might
have just hung upon any four but no
worries distraught the bishop back to F
to D 5 e 597 oh I don't really want to
play d4 here but he's going Knight c5 so
I kind of have to also to close this
diagonal down as well like g4 gets super
aggressive probably not the right idea
here but I'm gonna try it anyway so
takes Knight b6 whoa what is that
I'll take g3 if Knight c4 I'm gonna just
swing my queen won't lean over to g2 or
f2 f2 might have been slightly better
but not a big deal see - it's not
holding all the glue together but so
Queen 85 now I can play f5 this is why
they clean as much about our 1/2 - I
must say so I'm gonna play a five-night
b2 I'll play off 6 I think because now
now the bishops attacking the rook so
and now after with be a trick p2 he's
just down and down a whole Rock cuz
Queen c3 I take be able to chock ropes
e8 but that doesn't create a threat to
all this player ok - I'll give him the
knight on c3 and then I win the bishop
on a6
Zen harmonix rights do you have a
regular day and time ustream um not at
the moment but I am actually around for
quite a bit now so probably I would say
in general sometime in the early
evenings probably I'll be streaming
maybe something like ground like 5:00
Eastern if I have the chance the only
problem right now is there there also is
the the Yankees Astro series and those
games are starting insanely early early
at least last you how it starts like
5:00 Eastern I think so
but I would say early evening I will be
streaming probably for the next week I
would say more or less Bishop a3 okay
I'll take at 97 93 c6 and now I was just
going to lose a piece so I've point a 5
hitting as king and as a knight on a 3
so Ches Marcus writes hi from Argentina
Hikaru if you were not a professional
chess player what would you have done
I'm not actually sure there are many
different possibilities you know that I
there are many different ways I could
respond to that you know I think I think
most likely I probably would have done
something at finance or something in
politics one of the two I mean when I
when I when I went to when I when I went
to college I was studying political
science so it's possible I would have
done something and that obviously I'm in
politics even even what like ten years
ago now compared to what what it is
today is significantly different so
there's I don't know what I would have
done probably would have been something
in politics or something in finance one
of the two I think almost for sure so a
six I'll play c4 probably knight c6
Queen d2 and kit in case you're trying
to be funny a TR TR x TFW I did say
political science not political what did
you write political political silence or
oh dude I'm history I thought someone
wrote political silence sorry maybe I'm
just blind um okay so visually 7gb - I
thought so they're trying to be funny by
saying political silence um I'll cast
takes takes probably 90 for Queen d1
I mean it takes out three I'll take I
have six I could play no b3 is a bad
move I'm just gonna play Bishop g5
probably Brooke c1 or if d1 or actually
I'll just play b3 first support the pawn
on c4 probably works c1 Knox work c1
work d1 play Bishop d2 drop the Bishop
back maybe play 495 discoveries Queen h5
interesting all this take and I'll play
Brooke c1 just play some kind of an
endgame if he takes wants to take or he
doesn't want to take okay so now I'll
play play Knight d5 here yeah I think I
will just play Knight e5 why not
although here it's it's gonna be hard to
win this again because I'm getting this
structure which is favorable but with so
few pieces on the board on it's hard to
take advantage oh but II six is a bad
move because now I'm gonna no I am gonna
get some pressure he's got these two
Center pawns that are a little bit leak
here hang out seven I'll play Bishop a5
hit the rook force it to d7 play rook e3
now I can't double I've got rooked III
woke up three rook up three rook e1
I mean Black's still probably fine but
everything is just very slightly loose
here for blacks or d5 okay now it's the
moment of truth do I want to check yeah
I think I want to check on f3 and then I
think I take on d5 but actually wait but
no this doesn't quite work see his rook
d5 hmm
I kind of miss played this okay yeah
that was bad okay rook to e3 because now
is d4 which I just completely overlooked
for some reason okay this is gonna be
hard to win as well now so okay I'll
play
g3 D formatively Bishop d6 b is rook c3
yeah or whoopsie - I guess okay but now
I can take the pawn and I'm gonna be up
a pawn so this is this is a draw an
endgame I'm gonna be up a pawn where
it's drawn in game but I'm gonna find a
way to win this whether it's a flag or
over the board I'm gonna
way to win now Chuck take probably route
B to but now I think I can play H for
now it's not so trivial this is still of
course a draw but it's not so simple
actually
and in fact here after 85 I can play
King G to a 4 B 4 and keep his King here
keep his King locked up like this here
on H 6 and again it is a drop but there
are definitely some tricks now and now
after g5 wait a second rook be 6 KH 5 so
I take I take on each 7 and this surely
has to be winning okay we're case seven
or a cage floor I think Brooke age 4
makes more sense
ok 3 I'll play with c4 gingy to a4 I'll
play rook c5 King g4 I play off 3 so
he's gonna have to go back I'll put the
rook and behind the pawn or k2 I'll play
g4 23 okay one king out for a - I can
play f3 and now this is just technically
winning because now I can just use my ax
I can now just use my rook in my pawns
and just push all the way off the board
so he's gonna have to go e to at some
point and then I just play off for g5
and this is just completely winning now
shock him teenage 6 IG v ur cage subs
ways to go back now I play chief 5 King
Jay Kingi sixth threaten made on the 8th
King on 6 threatened me to gun if he
goes G I've rookie this is gonna have to
go to eat and then I just go out 5 and
it's just all over
all right so okay next game d4 Knight f6
c4 all playing games though or no I
won't play them so I'll make it
interesting I'll play it by noting the
worst opening out there g6 I have three
I'll play a six threatened d5 will play
a four of course play Bishop g4 three
takes Knight B to d7 Bishop g7 first was
maybe a little bit better
might have bitched about for now but who
cares Queenie sub and protect the pawn
Bishop g7 it's gonna castle castle Queen
g3 now I could take the pawn fact it's
probably the best move here but I for
some reason don't want it so I'm just
gonna play 98 rook e1 protecting the
bishop okay so now I've got a co-op with
a plant so I'm gonna play rook c8 try to
play for c4 maybe Bishop g4 that's a
move and after h5 what is his idea okay
it's gonna take interesting me five take
all take I'll play 96 next or night g7
y'all play 96 this is not really what I
was hoping for out of this opening us
more because it's gonna be very hard to
play for a win as opposed to anything
else but still a lot auto mod look at
whatever I just awesome message okay so
94 takes takes play rook e8 kick the
Queen off the off the e-file play rip d8
now he's probably got to play work edie
one because we're KD one hangs is pawn
in a four although Queen d5 is not
actually a threat here so it's not
actually necessary our now you plays
riff d1 place c4 I think I will play C
for Queen d4 Queen b6 I want to get
those rook here to c5 ver que c1 I'll
play B v a5 rook c5 so Casey
b5 takes takes I have a feeling we're
headed for another one of these end
games where I'm gonna end up up a pawn
but I'm not sure let's see so I play B
for Roxy 1 or c8
Queeny for now if I play c3 here he's
gonna take take fricassee to I think I
take because my queen controls the h2
square so he can take the pawn on c3
because I ll subject me Chuck Network d1
since when Queen covers this h2 square
so now Queen e1 I play deep no sorry not
Rafi - Rafi 352 it just takes takes and
rook takes a it is Chuck so rook d3 to
prevent anything again he can take
so yeah again I don't see any more
questions in the middle in the meantime
floyd akash writes what are your
thoughts on s chess by ash chassis or
he's referring to Sarah want chess
another variant that I like but I feel
like somehow it's a little bit too
different that it's never going to go
mainstream in that you have these these
different pieces that come on to the
board and while it's very creative I
feel that it's it's a little bit too
different it's kind of like you're
introducing is you don't have the same
same like you you have you know the same
pieces more or less the same set of
rules with all the other variants and
with us shuts you're introducing new
pieces and I feel like it's you know I
enjoy playing it but I think it's a
little bit too different and it's never
going to become that mainstream so in
the meantime take stakes play d8 rook b8
hopefully work da if he takes I've rook
t2 and he's getting made it
now as Kings wide open here so work Ito
I'll play Queen f3 maybe or not I don't
know
mostly what am I missing here so rook c3
is not a threat right so he's
threatening or ki-yay that's his mean
that's his trump so if I play rock T to
work c3 work d1 or a key a takes takes
king h7 I think I'm winning so as I
think you'll you guys are gonna see here
it's gonna take I play work do you want
he's gonna play rook e8 I'm gonna take
he's gonna take I'm gonna go King g7 and
he's gonna be unable to stop Chuck main
here on each one
so Joker I assume that's a reference to
to Novak rights hi from Riverside
California always wanted to know what
you see in your mind during calculation
on you know in general it's just I'm
basically just moving the pieces in my
head sometimes like when I'm doing it
while I'm playing here online I will
actually kind of be looking at the board
and visualizing on the board on because
during an actual game is just like
basically just a board and just moving
pieces I'm putting them back I'm looking
at a different line and so forth I know
I make that sound way too simple it's
obviously not that straightforward
but yeah that's more or less what I do
so okay so let's see okay so 95 Knight
f6 now I think this is bad because this
would be for if I remember I think
there's before Queen c6 there should be
five might just be like game
Ola
submission before I mean Queen sistex is
the only move I don't see any other
moves
so we'll see what he's gonna do
twitch guy writes I thought Nakamura was
from Japan I was born in Japan I have a
very mixed background I have an American
mother Japanese father but I do
associate myself much more so as an
American having grown up here
okay so he resigns okay so that's
another one in the books up till 11 I'm
trying I'm gonna try to beat this by 20
if I can get to 20 I'll be pretty happy
and then um then I'll find someone else
so I'm gonna play Kings Indian this time
something a little bit different see
what he wants to do c5 c3 Queen b6 three
knight c6 I'll let him exchange the
Queen's if he wants to maybe he will
maybe one so he plays Bishop c4 saw
Castle so he plays so he castles now
yeah I'm gonna play 95 force force his
hand force him to exchange Bishop b5
I'll play Knight d5 attack the bishop on
a for an hour treat to c7 kick this
Bishop out also now I'll just play
Bishop e6 Knight g5 but 95 doesn't
create an actual threat so I'll just
play I'll play Bishop f5 I'll try to
provoke him into playing efore and
weakening this this these pawns here in
the center so he plays rook c1 not
surprisingly so h6 now I'll play now
retreat back to e6 again although I just
gave him b4 he just missed b4 he put the
rook on c1 he had this discovery here
was before on my on my night so he
actually just completely messed that
that would have been very very strong
it's a 93 I'll play work out c8
a ch3 I'm gonna play I think I played g5
here just to take away any ideas of
night f4 and then like night c4 or
something Bishop g4 reason we'll move on
and play a5 kick the bishop it's about
7:00 maybe I'll play e5 here maybe I
won't but I just want to see what his
his ideas as well because it's not
really clear what either of us are doing
or one of us has to come over the plant
so he retreats yeah I know I'm gonna
force his hand play e5 takes a plea for
efore f4 playoff for also but I think
this is bad so I think I take play e4 if
95 I think I just take take stakes ok
it's not so clear alright so if I take
he takes I think I'll just play b5 here
cut off this c4 square from the night he
doesn't have this anymore
so he goes night if one I think I'll
play Knight d5 here I'll give him this
b5 pawn because I want to go f4 Bishop
takes e5 so let's see what he what he
wants to do here Bishop h4 all this take
rook e1 e3 of course night h2 good move
and I could play Knight takes c3 here I
don't really believe in it but why not
after this article this surfer wrote
about me a liking works much more than
two pieces I kind of feel a block
obliged to go for this so Bishop e7 rook
c7 9 f3 but now I can just retreat my
Bishop back to g7 and so now actually
I'm just a pawn so this Bishop still
hanging at the same time my knight is in
fact this Bishop doesn't have many
squares now
so someone so I'm running through the
comments I see you know like someone's
someone wrote I recognize most of flags
that's that's not so much that I
memorize them it's just you know when I
was younger I I write read a lot I mean
and when you read a lot try to gain
knowledge about the world in general I
think that it's it's much easier to
remember flags and and also the other
thing is that having played trust for so
many years who tend to see so many
different players at different
tournaments and for the more serious
international ones generally that they
have flags at the board so that helps as
well so g3 I could play e2 there are
there many ways to win this here I think
I'm gonna play Bishop h5 basically to
force and I want him to go g4 so I have
these two connected passed pawns here
and I'm just gonna go for bush before
and try to run the often the e pawn
right down the board there should be
seven this before and it's actually
turning out exactly as I was hoping it
would so he's gonna have to move his
knight now King g2 just loses to rook a
to I mean he just resigns and stud okay
so next game play b3 Bishop b2 Bishop g4
knight of three takes takes probably I
had this earlier against a different
players gonna play g3 a for Bishop g2
castles d3 92 pretty standard a3 a4 b4
probably play c5 I'll play c4 Queen c7
22 c8 interesting I'll play a rook e1 no
probably work d1 or something along or
work c1 maybe I think I'll play work c1
try to maybe do something here along the
C file
so let's see what is nice when we place
Queen beats and I'll play 95 he takes
I'll take because now I'm gonna take on
d5 we're gonna get this slightly off
paunch structure I think takes 95 d6 of
course I'll take now I can play e6 yeah
why not
he'll take take g7 take e6 and now it's
Kings very open to soive Queen B to work
e7 ideas
d5 is hanging so he probably has to move
this knight or it can play d4 play play
rook e7 because now I can't go to a fake
sign he'll hang aged seven suits gonna
have to go to go to like eh-eh now
there's got to be some way to punish him
so Queen C for cleanup sevens one idea
and it looks like the best one actually
because 95 I go Queen e6 that's like
right now for example that relating how
a previous question like I'm just
looking at the board and saying what I
see so it's very straightforward when
I'm playing online as opposed to on over
the board of course and blitz over the
board as well it can be pretty similar
to so I see this question it's a good
one
I think is chess Pedro de puts written
by the foss it says would you rather a
be trapped in a crowded New York subway
for 10 hours with Mikael towel chain
smoking cigars cigarettes for the entire
time or be trapped in an apartment in
Iceland as post-911 for three days after
a huge snowstorm I think it's pretty
obvious that for me that answer would be
stuck in the New York subway with
Mikhail towel for 10 hours certainly I
think he was a genius in a sense of
course Bobby was as well but I I get the
sense that with towel at least it was
always everything was always in good fun
he he enjoyed life a lot I think with
Bobby there were certain times when it
was definitely not fun and a lot of you
know crazy things to be said so
definitely be the first one out of those
two things so yeah
and of course if I strap will tell for
sure there would be alcohol too because
he was a well-known alcoholic as well so
it would be a it would be much more
enjoyable to be with him
certainly so okay this time I want to
play I'm gonna play Grunfeld something a
little bit different it's gonna be three
I'll take castles play Knight a6 gonna
play one of these lines a6 of course is
the main line but this one's you know as
a Gary Gary special for a long time in
the late 90s before I think it's Queen
b6 there's at 94
I don't remember I'll play 94
so yeah okay
he's still thinking oh no you play
Bishop g3 sorry I just wasn't blind
there for a second you guys okay Bishop
g3 um so I can take on c3 which looks
pretty reasonable and play were key for
maybe play 96 also which looks pretty
reasonable too I think I'm gonna go with
90 so I think he has to take now excel
her wise he's gonna lose a piece
although I did have Knight c3 as well
actually I just summers I didn't even
see that but um okay cleanup force now I
can take I can go Knight e4 back just
play Bishop f8 this is very interesting
okay I think I'm just gonna take a crook
rook d8 this yeah I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna play this on game since I'm
unsure of what's going on so he's gonna
take on c3 I would assume
I mean maybe he'll take any six I'm not
sure I don't think so cuz then i just
take b2 so he does take so I'll take
I'll take I'll take play worth b8
there should be five there's efore about
four and I can play both but bish before
still looks very good hitting the pawn
attacking the knight on f3 so probably
he'll play d6 and he doesn't this very
dangerous past pawn but with doubled
pawns my knight being able to come back
and block it I should be doing fine so
92 which I don't really understand I
think I can just take I mean unless he
wants to play ignite c4 of nights before
I've like rookie 4 or something tonight
if one I'll just drop the rope back to
e8
if there's g5 rook d7 93 bish piece 93
97 maybe okay he plays Bishop f6 so it's
he's just playing something completely
different so I'll just play Knight b
a.push b 6 and now if he takes the rook
I get to take back with the night and
then as bishop won't be able to stay on
f6 an action in this position without
Queens on the board I'm doing very well
because this won't have sex is
nice and pretty but it doesn't do
anything so rook takes 97 he's gonna
have to go like push page 4
our Bishop g5 for example let's play off
six kick the bishop further I'll
probably go to h6 or a four play g5 trip
d6 just bring liking closer I'm gonna
play b6 next move probably okay place c4
but by playing C before he puts it on
the same square as my bishop and now I
think I might not have to plead b6 like
maybe I can just play rook b6 in
exchange the rooks cuz c4 is so loose so
Rick d1 o player k-6 now I'll play
Knight d6 and and yeah by putting this
pawn on c4 he really really created a
big weakness which was very very
unnecessary now how to win this quickly
I'll just take don't take I'll take I
think I'll just play work a2 now yeah
and now have you takes c4 I mean the two
pieces are really back so I've got just
so many pawn so takes Knight c8 and now
I'm just up two pawns no real worries
here opposite color bishops that's the
only danger here
but bring my bishop back cover all these
all these you know create squares for
the night so he can't really attack up
696 for ELLs play h6 tinks I'll take h4
I'll check pick up another pawn now I've
got like three extra pawns I think now
I'll give him the exchange so I know
this is winning with the pawn so so
widely split he doesn't want to exchange
I'll play 97 I have two knight c6 c7
I'll just play d5 start start getting
the pawns going Bishop f5 keep
dominating the Knights we just no good
squares letters tape King e6 and now I
mean it's just now it's just routine all
the pawns go right down the board okay
so it's 14 6 more to go
push by v g3
9h four three Bishop g2 just keep
playing normal moves sevens play e3
see five up lady 392 castles castles
eighty-seven I'll take know I can play a
four I think I'll play up for not
naughty for not yet at least
and now I really want to play like e4 e5
open the diag for the bishop okay so
they plays b5 now I completely for ya
I'll play you for b4 I'll just play e5
takes takes a d7 but now I get c4
might be six so play Queen e2 see a
knight of three basically as long as you
don't got some Knight d4 were we right
here I have two pieces that can that
cover the square as opposed to one piece
so now now I'm no I'm doing fine so I'm
gonna expand here h4 g4 h5 maybe not
sure yet if that's my long-term goal but
it's one of the goals I have here so
please push my fate like king h2 i
probably gonna put the knight on chief
I'm just waiting for another move or two
to see if he wants to put the night on
he's stopped him but he clearly does
it's no I'm just gonna put the knight on
e5 now I plays 94 I'll take d4 I don't
have to take here I really don't have to
I can also play h5 maybe h5 yes what
because I'm by taking giving this pawn
on d4 he might be able to get a knight
to c5 and then the pawns not so bad but
here if he exchanges rooks on d1 I
haven't given this extra c5 option for
his night so he's it's kind of the same
thing but it's better here she doesn't
have 97-95 there should be seven okay so
now he's trying to so if I take he's
gonna take on qi5 I take on a seven I
take on f7 and what is going on I'm up a
pawn is it a good pawn bad pawn it looks
like a good pawn
I'll do it so take take queen g6 now
I'll exchange the rooks and I'll go
queen g4 hit the pawn on d4 cuz now like
now he doesn't have time to get his
Knight to c5
now I'm also threatening Bishop b4 as
well
it's a queen h7 I don't know what that
does I'm just gonna go King G 1 and now
e 6 is hanging on so now he's like and
I'm also threatening g6 2 so Queen h7
was a very very bad move
so what's I see question number 3 I'm
missing question number 2 I don't get
question number 2 question over to looks
like just a statement not a question um
anyway back to the game so Queen g6 now
I'll go for now on Queenie ater
just go Queen h4 I'm just Chuck meeting
him on the H file
I think Queen h4 g6 yeah I'll just play
g6 to lock it in here so there's no way
you can stop clean age for cleaning
yourself in me or 97 maybe he was 97 9f8
maybe they still lost but 97 prevents
maid at least
so eat g6e for c6 Knight c3 d5 I have
three I'll play Bishop chief for I guess
yeah why not
Bishop III Bishop g7 okay so getting
back to the chat so what was question
number three question over three was
would you rather a be forced to answer
the foxes would you rather in chat or be
lose twenty blitz games in a row to Eric
Hanson live I think it's pretty obvious
with that that that answer is I mean
without a doubt it would be a would
would you rather there's no way that I
would want to lose to Eric 20 games in a
row that would be like that would be
like the worst thing ever that would be
such a disgrace
tonight it takes e4 Knight of six
probably he'll take I'll take with a
pawn castles castles or h3 first doesn't
really make a difference what order he
plays it in so c3 I'll play 97 h3 Bishop
e6 92 Knight b6 might be three um what's
the best way of proceeding or just play
rook e8 I'll let them take the bishop
possibly I'm not not crazy about it
probably I won't if he goes 95 I'll
probably play Bishop see a submission
about 4 play 95 probably Busch Beach -
now I'll play b6 just to prevent 95
although kind of my structures not ideal
here I don't really like the position
that I've gotten but I'm sure I'll find
a way out so a5 try to play a four a
three push about three I'll play a four
a three now
Queen c2 all this tank I played b5 try
to fix the structure you still can place
c4 but after takes and I'm doing fine so
takes I'll play Bishop f8 to stop any
nonsense here on this d6 square also
maybe now there should be four as well
so so we'll see what he wants to do here
with this next max a couple moves so
Rick a c1 I could play night before here
yeah why not it makes sense
non-threatening 93 with the family fork
hitting the the both Brooks and the
Queen on d3 but I'm also hitting this
pawn in a two and now potentially so
Queen b3 now that looks weird now I can
take a two I can also take D for now but
if I take d4 he just goes will do one
Queen c5 a3 doesn't look quite right 92
looks interesting as well this is tough
to play tough to play which one works
okay I'm gonna play yeah I'm just gonna
take the pawn in E - why not
Brooke it rook D one night before just
protect the pawn again and now I'm just
up a clean pawn and actually maybe I
broke 83 also I didn't quite see it um
but the position still is very very good
for me it's a 95 Bishop age - I'll just
play Queen d7 and now I'll try to play
like rook da and slowly untangle here
so why White has a little bit of
pressure here I can't really move this
knife from d5 to Knight b6 I'll just
take click before d5 if takes I'll take
with the Queen obviously
fish before now huh I'm gonna play age
five try to expand a little bit here on
the kingside there should be three
rookie six threatening c5 now but no I
don't like c5 Semite then Queen B five
my queen is too loose so I'm just gonna
try to play F 5 F or try to hammer him
here on the on these dark squares now
you can play rook c1 again but rook c1
maybe I just go Bishop e3 force the rook
off a one or off c1 sir and then I can
go like Bishop d6 maybe because now if
he takes anything on c6 I have this page
to chuck now a 4-3 and no no I get that
no I get the big Chuck on eh 224 and
this is something pretty much over I can
win this many ways I'll just I'll just
sack the rook um and yeah okay so let's
see so that's 16 to 4 more to go that's
that's my goal get it up to 20 get back
to playing normal openings for a bit so
e4 Knight I forgot to put the bond clock
oh I just forgot about that all I'll
keep that in mind for next game actually
I completely forgot about that
so yeah so next next word I'm gonna try
to get that as well
it's a d5 pointing one takes tix cd5
Bishop g5 now this is known to be bad
for black actually but but he's gonna
try and play this
someone says why you drink water at home
but redbull during tournaments well
frankly it's just it's a little bit hot
down here in Florida for starters and
secondly when I when I come onto stream
for the most part I don't really want to
have to run to the restroom that much or
interrupt the stream as much as much as
it's possible so so in general that's
why I do it and also I attended if I'm
doing a stream which is gonna be a
couple of hours it's it's a little bit a
little bit better to be drinking a whole
bottle of water rather than a couple of
a couple of Red Bulls okay so Rick be
eight now how does this go I know this
is not supposed to be good for black but
why exactly is it's not supposed to be
good for black is it busy summer isn't
94 first I think it takes 94 yeah I
think it just takes 94 the c3 how does
this go exactly this doesn't look quite
right somehow so I could go Queenie so
so 94 c3 Knight c3 rook b2 looks very
dangerous but I do believe it's 94 here
maybe I maybe I'm just insane or
something who knows I'm gonna go fourth
dozen sigh I'm sure I'm sure this has to
be the right right move
although I could be wrong if I'm wrong
only problem is is that I'm just gonna
lose this game that's the problem
whoa rook me too wow what is that okay
so he's trying to get the same Osso if I
think he wants to play okay he wants to
play no what does he want to do here
okay let me try Narcy and so by Chuck c3
so I check King moves so takes rook a a
can we see one c3 nice too much take
probably or not okay I don't have a
whole lot of time I'm just gonna have to
blitz us out and hope that I'm not
losing on the spot rook c8 we're be a
king c1 c3 Knight c3 looks like it's
okay I mean there's no guarantee this is
okay so he plays to see through first I
have to take his queen before Kings see
one Queen c3 rookie d1 not great I don't
think it's losing on the spot but who
loses very dangerous
and this could very easily be losing I
just I I don't see it losing on the spot
but it is very very dangerous and black
here probably has at least a draw
between a one queen d4 I don't think he
has more than that okay so he plays
between c4 so he's trying to win or
something but now I can just take the
pawn yeah this he had Queen e1 Queen d4
I think that was the best that he had
because now okay let's say I can play
work d2 maybe
no then he's been he's gonna play Queen
c2 okay so he's got his ideas of I go
King D 2 to Keaney 1-shot Keaney one
check rook D - yeah okay I'm going king
d2 and I'm gonna hope that I'm not lost
here because of if I can get my king
over to f2 I'm just gonna be up in
exchange and winning and blacks king is
open here as well so it's not so simple
now I go c3 I think or no actually just
go route d2 just worked you - yeah and
no no I should be fine because now I
have King f2 as well so I really didn't
play that very well I just forgot the
the right order but um but yeah so Queen
B 1 King off - and now no I Kings
completely safe now I have no no role
issues here I know I can just like slow
it down let's play c3 simple just like
put the pawn on a dark square try to
consolidate everything get my kingdom g1
and now I know I can save so I can just
like do anything pretty much okay Ricky
1 to 6 although I see that the time here
is pretty tight so okay so takes I'll
take I'll check I'll take I'll play
Queen d4 or not Queen d4 OGG probably
not I mean I don't really want to play
this but whatever maybe he doesn't see a
- is hanging no I surely you must see it
as he disconnected or am i disconnected
who's what's going on okay that was very
weird I don't know what happened there I
guess he got disconnected um anyway
seventeen in a row three more to go
three more three more for glory
so d4 okay what to play oh I'll play
another benoni if I get the opportunity
I guess I'm not gonna get that
opportunity so I'm just gonna play this
is a little bit weird I think this is
bad for white sometimes miss played this
a little bit so if I the Knight d5
Bishop g3 and I just take the pawn my
just up a pawn here get this b5 salt
tank guess I'll take with the pawn yeah
I mean he doesn't really have much of a
choice the 97 maybe night a3 Knight c3
both are possible or 92 I'm just gonna
play queen c6 maybe plays 94 I'll play
b5 please see for elders castle
now let's play d6 it takes I probably
I'm gonna take the rook I'm not sure but
my king is not that open here since
white doesn't have a dark square bishop
I think it makes sense or just if he
takes the pawn I'll just take a look so
I'll make the pre move d7 38 I mean he's
he's getting a getting um he's got one
pawn for it but that really should not
be enough here I play murky Sonny's got
94 so that I could be annoying Bishop a5
Bishop g4 takes takes this could be
slightly annoying so I was playin e7
don't see what he wants to do here h4l
display fish about five or vision for
our up lateshbhai five and work 88 is my
next move at the h5 I think I'm just I'm
just gonna grab the pond no reason not
to
and Kilgore 22 and not another crypto
question you guys really do like your
Kryptos I've noticed um was whether I
prefer BTC or BCC so that's a Bitcoin or
a Bitcoin cache I don't have strong
feelings I mean I think I am NOT a I
don't know a lot of the technical
details surrounding either of them but I
lean towards a Bitcoin in general
question 5 would you rather a loose the
scholars made against eric hanson live
in front of a crowd of 80,000 s or be
never be able to play chess with your
f-pawn ever again once again that's a
very very simple question for me to
answer that would obviously be that
would have to be the answer would be I
would much prefer to never play chess
with my opponent lose to Eric in front
of 80,000 people again that would be
about the worst possible thing that
could ever happen
so Queenie seven so I mean again it's
I'm gonna slip a clean exchange here I
just have to be a little bit careful on
how to use this D file how basically -
you know infiltrate on this D file or
exchange pieces because here I'm just
left to clean exchange right now so I've
got my queen controlling this whole D
file so I'm gonna go over and actually
here maybe I'll take and play a five I
could not really nuts so I'm just gonna
play rook d8 again maybe now I'll go go
ship d3 trying to exchange something
here in the middle of the board
Queen a4 Okla 27 probably he'll take no
play Queen b3 so now I'm gonna take I'm
actually gonna go the other way I'm and
try to open it up here instead so takes
try to try to use this extra exchange in
this outside a pawn to my advantage to
a4 a5 I'll play a three c5 man okay he's
gonna get another three on three but
this this should probably be losing I
think if we exchange Queens I'm not sure
but I think it's I think it's losing I
know I'm definitely not giving him a
draw that that much is very clear
g3 um okay I'll take
h5 i'll play keno 6 i have 350 for
Bishop g2 I think I'm just gonna take
and go King g5h for Roxy 3 3 5 to Roxy -
and now I'm just gonna play H 3 H 2 or
actually I might wait I just must play
this yeah I did actually
that was not good
so again I'm gonna have to fly him so I
terribly must play the son game
okay so anyway alright so okay eighteen
two more to go this time I'm gonna use
the bond cloth if I get the chance
oh why not who cares this g6 why not one
hang out - I'm just trying to get rookie
one trying to finish development here if
I can and it looks like I'm gonna get
total development so I think I'm gonna
be okay here
96 I'll play c3 so he loses d4 square
and I'll play d3 b6 I think I can just
grab here with Knight c5 now I've got
this nice diagonal funny thing is he's
moving fast so I assume he thinks that I
just I I slipped with the mouse but now
I'm just left two pawns everything's
everything is looking very very nice
only d8 now I've got to be careful here
though so rip d8 so I can play Bishop g5
maybe that's one option d4 is not really
an option fish before doesn't really
look like a good move he's not
threatening anything specific so I'm
gonna play Bishop g5 now I'm gonna play
rook b1 I just need to get my king over
2 G 2 and then I'm completely fine
basically just need like one more move
Bishop a5 g 4 C 4 C 4 C 4 Bishop e3 at
Bishop d3 queen d3 so I'm very close now
if I can consolidate in the next move or
two like maybe even just just c4 here
maybe and I'm just I think I'm just up
to pawns
there are obviously counter plates I've
lost so many tempo so so many Tempe in
my pieces are kind of not ideal but I
think I'm very close to being okay now
very very close
d8 so I'm going to play Queen c2 or b3
Queen c2 looks robbed that rook d 454
Bishop e3 maybe okay Bishop g3 54 I'm
gonna play work efore because I am up to
pawns here so please work d8 so I'm
gonna have to take them out to play h3
there is definitely compensation River
block that's what I will say even though
I'm an I'm up to pawns here there is
compensation without a doubt but if he
doesn't play he doesn't get something
really fast and he's just kind of
playing these wasteful moves he's just
kind of lost you need to play h5 and try
to create counter play immediately
except now after getting my King here at
g2 like fish broth - he's just
completely lost so he just wasn't
feeling the dynamics question 7 who you
consider your best point in time trauma
besides Magnus I mean without a doubt
it's gross shock no doubt crush chuck he
by far and away as the best player in
time pressure so I would have to put him
as the top top guy so it looks like
Cardoso is disconnected I mean I'm a
little surprised you disconnect but uh
anyway I'm not sure maybe it's not this
connection maybe I should see is a bad
connection because II don't most got
disconnected that not one game before so
so we'll see actually in fact here he is
he's back so the battle continues so
we're calf or I could take I could just
play Bishop III I'm not sure I'm just
gonna tickle him for a move make him
lose like another 5 seconds maybe not
even 5 seconds he's gonna go work out
for and if I take e is h5 and it could
be a little bit nasty so I'm now I'm
gonna play Bishop e3 no maybe I'll play
d4 or maybe I'll just take I think I'll
just take and play like Queen 4 which is
a bad move so I just give me a 5 for no
reason
but okay after Queen c7 D for now I'm
gonna be able to open up the file for my
rook he's trying to go Queen g3 is that
actually a problem I was gonna play King
h1 if you plays Queen v3 Bishop g2 if he
takes on d4 I'll play Queen d4 threat
and Queen d8 now and in fact yeah now
Queen d8 now it's Queens coming off it's
just all over and the bond cloud lives
to fight another day I have to say I
think my score at the blond cloud is
extremely good I think it's I think I
think I've won almost every single game
that I've played it so well the SAC King
f3 I mean I've got so many more pawns
than than my opponent here that if this
if this isn't winning then nothing is
winning okay so that makes 19 I guess so
I'll play one more and then maybe I'll
find someone else after him or maybe
I'll just go on beating him if you guys
would prefer that b3 up guys g6 we
should be actually 7c v d5 I'll play are
actually threatening e4 so I have to
counsel first played b5 here hey so
let's play some kind of interesting
Banco gambit I'll take if he takes I've
got Queen a5 and he's just lost in one
move 94 game over and that's gonna make
twenty so you guys let me know do you
want me to plan more or do you want me
to find someone else
okay so everyone's saying find someone
else okay cool so so he did resign so
that's 20 games so okay so let's see so
who else is online daro maybe I'll
played ro some games it's on my comment
on my screen
once I can you guys let me reload the
page something seems to have happened
okay cool
and we're back
okay so yah coughs still there once
there's another thumb sitting down there
tiger tom is there let's see who else is
out there
no I feel like starting hello hello is
there anybody out there is there anyone
at all and for those who didn't get the
reference that's a Pink Floyd reference
so you can go look up the lyrics
so let's see so okay so challenging
yakov Tiger Tom wonderful wonderful time
I think I'm challenging daro - maybe so
let's see so who who is who is out there
actually
oh sorry actually yeah someone someone
just point that out yeah I got the lair
slightly wrong you're you're right about
the Hat
anyone home you were you're right about
that actually so okay so so where is
everyone like a fire flash or maybe
another one I've sent out like four
challenges let's see who else vanishing
dragon whereas where is everyone tonight
oh no I am right okay all right well
figure everyone has access to the
Internet these days so when I'm saying
something I'm not always sure if I'm
right or not
okay so g3 Bishop g2 Castle 3 an
actually I don't who fire flasher is
place c4 Willie please see fiber e5
hopefully e5 okay so he's gonna try try
to play something aggressive knight c6
I'll play rook beat one okay five
hopefully Bishop g5 each six maybe not
sure if they'll do it so yeah so I'll
take I'll play 83 Bishop g7 maybe maybe
97 a couple different ways to play this
action rights does anyone know what
actually I mean Carter highest rating on
chest comm was yeah on chest at home I
think I think I beat Eric I think it was
air occurred or an arrow did see one of
the two of them I think I beat I think I
beat one of them and I think I got a
three thousand like I want to say it was
three thousand on 76 or something maybe
it's a bit lower than that but I think
it was something somewhere high like
that or maybe this Arabic Falcon is one
of those three though I I don't I don't
remember which one specifically but is
one of those three guys ah
so I'm right okay 3077 against narrowed
its key okay yeah I knew it was in the I
knew it was really high up there in the
3000 I wasn't sure just how high but
that makes sense
Bishop e6 I'm gonna play workout c1
probably he'll take if he doesn't I mean
I might go Queen a7 I'm not sure yet
so let's see what he wants to do at four
okay no no I think I kind of have to go
for it
the queen of something so I kind of have
to force him to do something here to
take or I don't have to for something
goes night off five okay so now I played
b6 probably he'll go c6 Knight c7 and
this is kind of really weird play 94 I
can go back to f3 I can also put like
Knight b3 maybe or even just simply e3 I
don't really like III it feels too loose
93 94 c5 o c5 doesn't look right here
I'll play p6 here I'll actually play P
exile all make and place c6 and 97
Bishop g8 now I'll play rook e1 at the
same time it's 19 on c7 is bad but the
rook on b8 is also dominated too so I
can play Knight f3 if I want which I
think I will explain I have 3 try to
exchange Knights
so Mac 10 6 68 donated $10 you remind me
of a samurai well thank you Mac I
appreciate that I try to play like one
sometimes unfortunately it's very hard
in this day and age to play like a
complete samurai except on is so
well-prepared but I still do try it so
Queen d7 so obviously wants to go rook
e8 now it's known about to bring my
queen back so I'll put it on a four okay
it I'll play Queen c2 for okay five work
a one probably push page three okay
that's a reason one well player get one
anyway probably he'll take on g2 and
then I have to take because if I take
first he has Queen age three it's all
pre-move King tree - okay goes Ruby
eight back no I'll put the rope on e7
got seven okay so now he's trying to do
something here try and do something
aggressive so if I play I mean f3 is
here I don't really like f3 but I'm
gonna play it just because I don't see
what he has here in fact so okay 594
Bishop h6 I can take or just play you
through I'll play III here Burke f8 but
now how do I want to do is because if I
take it's no good if I play work f1 I'm
in trouble
just play off for maybe yeah why not f4
this is getting very very complicated
though which is probably good for me
because if he's a long time I should be
able to I should be faster than him I
would think so takes now I can play ever
GFO play tough I'll play GF I think EF
was also fine too but Jia looks
reasonable as well so 28th player okay
too
if he takes I'll just take d6 takes I'll
take got four I think I have 95 in 96
and Abhi's got Queen h4 still oh oh I
did not see that Queen h4 could be a
problem Queen h4 Queen d2 me me okay he
doesn't see it this no I just take I'm
gonna for Queen d2 and now with Queens
the Queen's come off the board him to
supper rook shocked actually I gotta be
careful I don't have I've got more time
but not okay well he just resigns okay
so next game let's see please for Oh
play Sicilian something different maybe
64 I'll take or Bishop e5 Knight f6 okay
I wasn't really expecting to play Bishop
e5 on 93 what's the move here which one
do I want to play I think I'll play
Queen c7 by 94 d3 I could take on b5
play e6 also everything's really
possible here I'm just gonna take the
knight though or the bishops are on play
Queen c6 and 93 g6
probably a ch3 at some point or just
fish before first Bishop g7 we need you
to play age six don't want to give them
fish page six here so make some sounds
for key one play what will I play here
probably g5 why not there should be
three nights you for maybe this is very
unusual to want to playing this and it's
probably not good but I suspect I'll get
away with it
and who is whose fire flasher exactly
does anybody know right off since I'm
not gonna flip the screen d4 okay that's
a reasonable move I'm just gonna play
there should be seven I'll give him d5
if he wants it please work a d1 just
gonna Castle that's a weird position cuz
it's like I've got two bishops but he
can play d5 a five and close both
diagonals if he doesn't he might be in a
little bit of trouble actually it's kind
of hard to find good moves for white
hair I mean he's got the Knights he can
put it on maybe he can go a Knight d5
Knight e5 also that was the other option
or d v e5 he's gonna do one of the two
probably so III mean ii v is kind of
move i would expect but all right expect
a good player to play it at least let me
put it that was 92 play f5 if i want to
be really bold and aggressive I think
I'll just play e6 though I'll just let
him open it up and I'll take and play a
5 so now he's got 95 possibly but I
could think I can just click Queen d6 or
queen he ain't maybe Queen e8 and he
can't move his queen off the squares
Queen e8 looks cooks not running out for
again and I'm trying to just play d6 as
well so I mean he can't move his Queen
because then he'll hang the knight on e5
so he plays that for but now I think
after D sucks I'm doing I might just be
winning because if he goes 93 I Bishop
d4 or 93 i taked queen trade Queens and
gonna ship d4 Knight f3 I trade Queens
take out for although after and I have
three trades he has rookie 7 at the end
please Knight to c4 but now I think I
can take and play Bishop a6 maybe cuz
takes rook e7 the trip d4 is also move
but no I think there's basic system here
because now after 96 gia Bobby's got
rookie 300 whoops that was a slight
blunder on my part because I thought
after TGIF for I just forgot he is
rookie three here and yeah now it's now
it's a game it's not gonna be easy to
win this this probably is winning but
it's not it's definitely not gonna be
easy or not that it's winning I probably
will win but it's probably not winning
in fact so there should be 556 per case
or a cup 7 d 7 or D 8 probably Roque 7
I'll check he'll take with the night
I'll play rook d7 or go play King f 1
very clever playoff for
and yeah this guy's pretty good actually
it's much better than the last guy
35 rookie seven although he's way too
low on time and there's no way he's
gonna survive this time scramble it's
looming
yeah he's just much too slow so all
right so that's two down
last attempt question number six would
you rather a test farm from 1950s
McCarthy as US Congress that Mikhail
Botvinnik is not a communist or a lose
at 2023
losing 23 chess world championship
against a recently converted North
Korean super GM Eric Hanson who I don't
even know the answer is that one I
really don't have a good answer for that
one
I know I Eric isn't in North Korea and
that's that's the problem so I don't
know how to respond to that question
Bishop g4 h 3g three fire flash I wrote
Internet is really bad I mean yeah
sometimes from time to time it is it is
quite bad on here but you know what to
do
it's a g6 I'll Castle just play Queen e2
MD three and a half for probably rook e8
so I really want to play c5 what he
wants to do so I'm gonna play a little
bit strain I'm gonna play strange house
I'm gonna play g4 I'm gonna play
actually strange is the wrong where I'm
gonna play incorrect just let me put it
that way
a5 okay so f5 now play e5 this kind of
is turning into like some kind of like a
closed Sicilian or something like that
it's a little bit strange so c500 play
c4
Thank You six Bush b3 attack the pawn
here on c5 rook c8 I could play b4
interesting I don't know sorry b4 is
impossible cuz the queen protects the
night on be sick so I'll just play b3
Queen d7 bish buff - just I really want
to move this Knight to c3 but I couldn't
do it because you had a d4 forking my
knight in my bishop okay so I go I'm
gonna play d4 so now I should be happy
so now what's next no play III probably
he'll play a five but I'm not sure that
he will
okay Knight B to try I want really want
to put this night on a four if I can
maybe in the right circumstance but
we'll see what what he's gonna do
so please Queen c7 okay now I want to do
something on the Queen side so I'm gonna
play rook b1 maybe to play b4 maybe not
- I'm gonna go night 84 I please b6 and
now I got b4 which is exactly what I
want it was to open up the Queen side so
take stakes so you could play b5 maybe
probably no I take C for no it's just
bad knight c6 I'll take on c5 if he
takes I will take on a5 try to further
open up the position a little bit not
play rook b5 hit the pawn on c5 so we'll
see what his next move is gonna be here
so rook b8 but now I can take right
because takes 4 P 5 CB 5 because he
takes I just take that I just take the
rope on d5
tonight c5 b c6 i'm he's in bad shape
it's a night before the trade i don't
really want to I could play ninety six
also which actually looks really good so
I'll do that instead Queen b6 blush it's
a free night
so I'll play another one before what to
do this time I will play a Sicilian
again but I think I want to play a
different one because I'm not gonna play
Knight f6 on those three or okay he's
gonna play an open side okay so I'll
play the Kalashnikov which I played
recently in the isle of man
it's guys trying to play like Magnus so
this is gonna be fun the knight f6
Bishop g2 Bishop g4 if f3 Bishop e6 he
doesn't play off three he's and probably
not in great shape on Queen d3 I've
night before d5 first which order makes
the most sons huh okay so if night
before Queen b3 so I'm just gonna play
rook c8 maybe a six night a3 b5 yeah
this looks this looks more correct
now if 95 I'll just take and play Knight
before Queen b3 is no good so probably
takes and just like 94 fall by Bishop a5
or 97 and G sucks so he does play Knight
d5 I'll take take so I'll play 97 95 was
also possible while 95 might actually
have been a better move than this but
that's still any way to 500 playoff six
mr. t - I'll play Bishop a5 probably
before he doesn't see - is hanging not
that I'll take it but it is hanging
[Music]
so place Queen b3 that's a weird-looking
move just play cheese sucks finished my
development there's a c7 c4 hmm this
isn't quite turned out how I was hoping
the wood really has it so I'm gonna
castle he's gonna take I'm gonna play
rock b8 and try to play it's like some
kind of a gambit this positions various
positions unclear why it might be better
here but figure with enough I should get
enough counter player no I'm gonna go
for a knight a5 psyche on there should
be three I'll play could play Knight f5
actually I can just take the pawn of b5
so why not
Knight see to Knight a5 right before
I'll take 23 is always there I'll just
play Queen e8 side stop it to play for
up 5 about 400 sidestepping with Queenie
it was back so I gave him room c7 which
was completely unnecessary so solacing
but yeah seven I'll play wicked I'll
tickle them a couple moves
and now I'm gonna come back with rookie
in a second wait 496 okay just rook e8
Queen b7 I'm gonna play you for close
this whole diagonal down because if this
bishop can get through ever then I've
got problems but now I've got III maybe
I also open up this diagonal for my
bishop as well so this is looking better
so Bishop f1 now I could take I could
play III also III up yeah I think III
make sensor so do if he pushes off on I
go E to plays rook e1 I'm gonna go up
for if he takes can't get away with this
really can you get away with this always
play off for I don't know if I force the
best move but I don't see it doesn't
look like it loses on the spot so I
might as well just go right after him
birkoff one so what is he trying to so
if I go eat ooh it's just gonna go
rookie one FG f FG rookie - and if FG f
GE - there should be two Queen e3
somehow I feel like this has to work
takes Queen III KH one Queenie for me or
I'll give it now just Queenie trainees
just busted completely because he
doesn't have kina shrieks out of this
pickle on d7 okay so this game I'm gonna
play b3 there should be to start with
something a bit more unorthodox again so
I have sex Bishop b5 there should be six
I'm play 98 395 what's a little be
two castles might be five Queen e7 all
I'll take the bishop he takes I'll play
I don't have to play Knight f3 I kind of
feel like an e4 Knight g5 probably so 96
I'll castle
if e4 again I'm going to go to hu 5 so
please Queen e7 I'll play d4 if or I can
play Knight e5 d 6 I'm just going to
play d5 c4 Bishop g4 h3 plays rook e8
open 92 a5 play E for 96 I'll play a 395
Queen c2
so I guess it's thinking quite a bit how
to proceed place 97 so now I'm going to
go be four because if you take sticks
then you can't take the pawn abhi Forks
is real honey it would hang so he plays
b6 I could play Bishop c3 I don't have
to I don't see any other moves that make
sense so I'll just play it might be
three was maybe possible as well but
doesn't really make a whole lot of Sun
so night night a fatal play Bishop d3 to
control f5 he's gonna go Knight g6 now
and it'll go g3 to cover the f4 square
rook a Fayette sir he really wants to
play for a five now now I could play f3
I can click Queen e2 also Queen to a5
takes takes Knight e4 Queen e2 looks
pretty solid here because now I mean
maybe it's someone I can also play see
five as well so plays three
I'll play where Kathy one Queen d7
now I do have c5 it is a possibility and
I'm gonna go for
[Music]
tonight night night p8 now I'm gonna
play c6 and when he moves the Queen I go
b5 and he just completely traps is
working his night here on 8mm b8
now if you plays 96 I'll probably go go
should be 5 so Queen e7 b5 and now it's
night and Rucker just dead for the rest
of the game
so positionally blacks blacks just lost
now
so a5 salt take I can take I don't have
to but there's no reason not to solve
this take I'll play a 94 93 probably
soon as reasonable and here are the
positions so good the basically like
black just has these two pieces that are
completely dyed so we've got three King
G to e4 only moved probably and then
just rip d1 and it's just I mean these
two pieces night on B and those work on
e8 can't can't ever get out sir we've
got six I'll play over KD 197 and I
could play f4 and I think I will play
cuz I mean he's got these two pieces
that are completely dead so I might as
well just try and open it up as fast as
possible
and yeah so I expect he's gonna resign
her to move her too so yeah so far so
good I don't think I've lost the game so
far not not to jinx myself or anything
but
man what's going on here is he flagging
something wrong which would be five
which one will I do here I'll play you
sex consoles my g71 a 6-1 I'll play 96
c3 I'll play Bishop e7 takes d5 you
might take or play e5 built or playable
play off six
I assume he'll take on f6 yeah
takes Knight c3 castles g3 which one
I'll play Bishop d7 maybe play for Queen
b6 at some point later on h4 187 h3
which I conveniently forgot about snow I
know I've kind of put myself in a bad
spot so I don't have to play for
compensation now so tonight 9500
clicking h8 I basically just hung upon
for nothing so there I go just jinxing
myself 94 Queen b3 maybe Bishop c6
okay so there should be five I'll click
queen you have to be careful about with
Mooji 6 H 5 all take few plays let's see
yeah Bishop d6 Bishop c6 maybe there
might be some counter play here actually
this I might have gotten lot a little
bit lucky here so I think he went for
something that he really shouldn't have
Knight h4 although yes 9 h4 is a good
move I actually missed this no locally
Queen f7 I've got nothing if I trade
good d 192
I don't know if this works probably I'm
in trouble here but I'm not sure so
takes I'll take I'll take I'll take I'll
go King have six or D five-ish be for
probably a three bit should be one G for
maybe rip g8 or g48 maybe a three there
should be one hit the pawn on e a
and again I've magically somehow
survived this like I'm still worse but
this might not be lost and I'm not sure
that this is losing or not this doesn't
feel losing somehow so I play a four try
to try to make him get double F pawns so
he takes my pawn now I'll take his
pawnees got F pawns instead of G and F
pawns now H E - I'll play rip d8 g3 now
how to use these pawns mint-flavored c8
try to bring the rook into c2 if I get
the chance
c5 now I could take actually that's
probably a draw if I take do I want to
take and make a draw or not no I don't
think I do wanna make a draw so I'm
gonna try to play on play with d8 King
see King c3 probably King d3 non play
Bishop d5
I mean I haven't lost the game yet so I
figure why not try I mean I can make the
drawing any time I want probably but to
not try would be a bit of a crime so now
I'm going to try and push the sage pawn
right down the board if I can h4 c 7 or
KH 8
nine f1 I can play were caged five maybe
yeah wreckage five because work the
athan he goes 93 and he still is work
age something by putting the rock on h5
you go is 93 I just keep pushing H by my
works on the H five instead of d8 so
rook d7 H 3 H 2 Bishop g2 B 4 B six
maybe
why not takes came out for if King III
I'm just gonna bring my work back
probably rookie six I would assume or
not no okay so now I'll take I know I
should be should be able to flag him you
know okay so I'll play you for okay
bonk loud time round to round two well
let's see how it works out this time
let's see how this works out so g3 age
five I'll play h3 just to stop eh for h3
type stuff I'm gonna go goes from G to
Knight f3 there should be seven Knights
g f3
there should be six Bishop g2 knight
Knight g5 also possibly know I've been a
g5 Queen c2 I'm gonna delay taking this
bishop until I absolutely have to
basically King v8 play rook e1 maybe and
King off one possibly okay now I play
sage for so now is gonna force me to
take
and positions not great but it's not not
lost and that's really all you can ask
for when you play the bottom plot is to
not be lost after about 10 moves to g5
I'll play Knight f3 try to hit this pawn
here on g5 probably Knight h7 now I'm
gonna play a3 maybe before maybe not I'm
not sure probably not actually because
b4 takes takes I feel like there's gonna
be some tactic here so I got it I have
to be a little bit more careful so I'm
gonna play hmm I'll play Bishop e3 d4
and I can play Bishop d2 but I think I
should just take probably deform maybe
CD for not not easy both moves make some
sense so Bishop d2 so I'm gonna play
play for B for our next move basically
that's that's that's my plan at least
and then please work up 7 so I'm I want
to play b4 here but I probably can't so
I'm gonna play work f1 protect first I
assume he'll play rook f8 and I'll play
b4
and I assume he's gonna take most likely
whoa workout three what Oh yikes is he
had 95 and c4 or something
ooh that could be a problem that could
be a big problem
so c4 Queen a 2-cd 3 king u1 I'm kind of
hanging on kind of c3 I played Bishop c1
it takes like king do on his Queen a4 so
I've got to go Keaney 1 so let's see so
what does he have here so he goes rook
c8 but now I'm gonna get off for now I'm
gonna be able to open it up again now
it's gonna go the other way now he's
probably in trouble here because now I
go Brooke c1 Roxy 193 maybe so I got to
be careful let's see okay so rooks to
193 takes takes rook off to I think I'm
holding on here so I'm going to exchange
from a player cuff to
see what he plans to do here take
snuggle Bush pops one up and eyes got 9c
to shoot 92 93 is probably a draw I
don't have to take the trough he gets
really low on time here though it's
Pleasant he5 now work out for there no
tricks right work out for Bishop d6
maybe okay I I'm just gonna take this
pawn on d3 I'm not sure if it's best but
Brooke got three ah but now I want to
take he's got Knight G to King off one
no I'm just gonna fly
so cleaning up three Quincy - maybe
clean off a tween point off to the bong
cloud lives another win wow that was
that was pretty rough but somehow I
survived that um that was not very good
but you know when is a win
yeah I'm trying to have fun for you guys
anyway otherwise what's the point of
playing on online okay so we're gonna
we're probably gonna have a repeat with
Sam alone we played last game Alaska is
not very good obviously we try to
remember how these lines go play makes
you sucks again there should be seven
four take ladies five five I'm just
gonna play this time I want to do
something different so how do I do
something different that isn't just bad
not sure if I can okay I'll play nice
for why not
g3 I could play Bishop g5 here maybe I
think I will take stakes for clean seven
I want to go Queen before I'll probably
play a3 though and stop that but we'll
see yeah he does don't play b5 probably
Knight c3 I'll just Castle Knight Queen
a7 actually maybe I should've gone
cleaning something first
yeah five but now I will go clean the
oven because now on 92 I can take the
pawn on f5 or I can take the pawn on e5
as well since this Kings on g1 so both
moves are available here
so yeah let's let's see what's it's
gonna be so he plays a night at 92 I
think I'm just gonna take the pawn on e5
taking on f5 was fine too but I think
taking on e5 makes more sense and here
he takes on the e6 I have Knight f3
Chuck's so you can't take on e6 tonight
a3 so probably King G to Knight c4
Knight f4 I think I can yeah a night
afore I can just take on d4 because now
it takes Knight of 394 and I'm just up
to pawns and now he's gonna have to play
at least six okay well I just resigned
to stud
okay so this game oh let's see
bond cloud here yeah why not you put a
pawn on c6 I don't think I've ever had
it Carl kanban cloud before that so this
is gonna be a new experience 500 play
rook e1 probably a 4 a 3
I wants to go one night you for Queen e2
or something but I'm gonna be to work b1
thank you for Queen e2 it's a de for
I'll take and I've survived again this
game i've wrote completely survived so
this came out out of the opening with
pretty much equality i think maybe i'm
slightly worse but it looks pretty
decent so I worked d8 I'll play page 395
I take so he's gonna have to go night
night a night off 6 probably and this is
looking better and better pretty much by
the by it by that by the second almost
like 'if I'm gonna go see for now like a
595 c4 probably although I don't have to
play it right away so I think I'll play
I'll delay I'll play 94 first then I'll
play c4 NOx move because here I develop
the develop the tonight first hit the
queen on on b6
now this is just getting this is just so
nice considering the opening this is
this is what you want out of the bond
cloud so queen a5 Bishop g5 is possible
Bishop d2 Queen on a5 looks slightly
misplaced so I think I'm gonna play
Bishop g5 here hit the pawn on e7
rook e8 okay now so he's put the rook on
EA now I can play g4 if I want to not
crazy about g4 here I think I might just
retreat I think I'm just gonna play
Bishop d2 now see he took the rook off D
so this rooks on a worst square here
maybe Queen b6 bishops III probably 986
could move 94 basically I'm gonna try to
force him to do something with his
Bishop Carroll I take or not take but
I'm gonna make him have to decide what
he wants to do take the Queen
night-night c5 probably all play Queen
e2 96 room D 1 D 8 but he has no he has
no actual tribe here so now I'm just
gonna side stuff with my King get the
king ordered g1 now it's just a normal
position now we just play chess so h5
I'll play h4 Queen c7 I'll click with
stage 3 try to force him to do something
with this night that's why throwing in
h5h for his backs now with the bishop
behind the pawn it's much better
so I'll take 93 Bishop c3 probably work
do you one maybe not no he doesn't want
to do that ok so please II 6 okay which
is a good move so e 6 so how to do
something here like an h2
Queen b6 I'll play for probably he'll
take I would assume maybe not plays 94
and if I take that makes no sense but I
can go Queen up to maybe force him to
play c5 an hour of d3 now the problem is
the pawns on c5 the pawn on c6 II could
have brought the bishop to f8 c 5 with
the knight on B 3 but now at the pawn
here it kills the kills the options for
the bishop the bishop has much less
scope now do one black is still probably
okay but now it's now black is probably
slightly worse as opposed to being
probably slightly better but before I'll
take yeah five will play between two two
point six seven Queen d5
v6 of the Queen d7 force them to trade
the Queen's because now I have work
eight seven at some point as well so I
think I can just take the pawn rook d8
and I could exchange I don't really want
so I'm just gonna plant the rook on d5
and yeah so he resigns okay so let's see
so next one okay
c4 I'll play g6 Bishop g7 d69 c6 Bishop
d7 Queen c8 probably d4 Spanish 3 more
bullet chess openings here so d 595
takes H 5 H 4
let's bridge chess rights how is naka so
good I mean sometimes I just play good
chess not always but sometimes queen g4
I've as I referred to I mentioned this
in a earlier game I mean I literally
have had this vision I think like a
thousand not a thousand times but like
probably at least a hundred times and uh
in a lit era a bullet chess re actually
Knight f6 was a better move aside a h5
right away
but he's gone deep into the tank here
unfortunately I think it's already too
late for white I am reading the chat a
little bit not not super closely because
I do it to focus but yes I am actually
reading the reading the reading the chat
from time to time just not literally
every psychics I have to focus
and mac-10 688 asked what's my favorite
variant someone asked us earlier as well
it would be crazy it would be a crazy
house at the moment the variant where
you capture pieces and they come back
and you can put them on the board
so eat one I can play Knight f5
what's a rook h8 I mean I don't really
want to exchange Queens here but yeah
what I've rods play Knight of five Queen
f3 just take sin RhoC h8 and I should be
pretty good Brandon run rights naka
who's your favorite commentator um that
would be Sevilla without a Peter Svidler
the the Russian Russian player
commentator I found his commentary to be
the most enjoyable in general if I want
to relax and uh and just just relax and
like drift off to sleep them off then I
don't mind listening to some of the
stuff that Peter Heine Nielsen does his
voice though it's it's very soothing
just like it puts you to sleep and you
relax very easily when you listen to
what he has to say
okay so what did he play so yes sir okay
so he's clearly lagging as well I mean
he's losing in the on the board too but
my opponent appears to be lagging quite
a bit here so King off one I'll play
work h1 King you - rookie
- probably king d3 I would assume fish
buff - hangs a rook rook up - hangs upon
King D 3 root G - so now I want a double
I'm also threatening to play Knight g3
and all of whites pieces just they're
totally lacking any harmony here and
fire flashes as thanks okay so I guess
that's that
so let's see who else is there on then
um let's see let's try this vertical act
accout was there tactics at act illa you
know put try to challenge him or fast
chance okay so he he wants to play okay
so it's okay somewhere I'm gonna get +2
per game so this is something very
serious to g6 play h3 53 probably
castles castles Bishop a5 I will just
play Bishop e2 I mean I I don't want to
think a whole lot at the start of the
game don't want to get way down on time
so it's not correct but I'm just gonna
do it just because so b5 I'll play CD 5
I'll take might play for Bishop d2 is
also moved 95 makes sense as well so I'm
just gonna go with whatever looks the
most natural so Bishop c8 so basically
he's now he's now given back the tempo
that he had he had he had an extra tempo
because I played Bishop e2 and he went
back to c8 so he gave back that extra
tempo which is very very weird doesn't
make make sense at all
so takes I'll play fish about three or
94-94 looks completely fine probably 94
here I would assume or a five open hc5
take steaks
Queen b6 now befores not really moves so
I'll play Bishop d2 maybe make some
sense at least put pressure on a5 if he
takes all the rook b1 try to trap his
Queen plays Knight e4 but now I can take
and play b4 and now a 5 is super super
weak and you can play a 4 but it's just
a free pawn Bishop d7 b5 looks like it
works so I'm gonna try it
so let's see what is his his next next
set of moves it's gonna be here so work
be eight so now I will I couldn't play
rookie a sex but I'm just gonna exchange
and play Queen b3 and try to play on the
put my work on b1 and use this past pawn
or actually first I'm gonna play Bishop
c4 hit the pawn on f7 so you guys onto
Bishop e6 I take away because now the
bishop is no scope along this diagonal
with the pawn on e6 now rook b1 a1 all
options are on the table okay one looks
okay one looks pretty good here
push phosphate now how to convert is the
question okay six looks fine rook b1
Bishop b4 Bishop e5 takes takes takes
takes yeah I don't know why I played
rook rook yet one that was stupid okay
let's play work B won't the idea of
playing Bishop b4 not smooth Queen c7 I
think I can play Bishop before takes
takes yes I can play Bishop before I
could have also played b6 as well but no
need to rush it is it's an extra pawn
who can't really do a whole lot so make
some songs but alright so let's let's
see what his next move is sorry about
that opana he says there's but always
been an echo yeah okay sorry about that
um I guess I'll have to change the
setting slightly but um oh well anyway
let's go Clippers let's go Clippers
I shouldn't Eric like be out there right
now I thought Eric was a twitchcon or
something I feel like he I thought they
were doing it at the arena but maybe I
maybe I'm wrong about that so I'm not
sure about that
Leonardo 0 donated $10 Thank You Lane
art I appreciate you're enjoying the
show I'll try to keep playing good trust
winning games
Queeny for bush five queenie 7 takes
everything's on dark squares so i can't
get away with it so i'm just gonna play
queen c5 exchange these bishops in b7
queen c5 so here he can't he can't move
the brook off of b6 because then I'll
play b6 myself so I'll check and now I
think I can go rook d1 yeah because
takes I've worked d8 wrote a chain mate
queen bee a interesting so if I take and
play work b1 I think this is winning
because my rook is behind the pawn here
yeah this is definitely winning now
because he had to play work b6 first but
then I was gonna go th your king h2 King
g3 king of four and I think I could I
was just winning anyway but all right so
D Fornaio six c4 on a plate g6 play
King's India and proper King's Indian
for a change
so let's see so d5 maybe DC 5 placing
this is a ancient theory ancient ancient
rook d1 like Queen 85 b3 so he really
doesn't want to push this pawn which
this is confusing me a little bit okay
so I'm gonna play B 595 what is he
trying to so if I take take night before
what's going on here I'm turning 93
checkmate I assume he'll see it but you
never know
I mean King up to might be the only move
here for him I mean he sees it okay I
wasn't sure I mean this looks like the
only try so Queenie a to take sakes dc5
looks like why it's okay if I play f5 to
really spice it up yeah why not let's
let's make this really really spicy play
off five try to really mess mess up the
entire position here
so let's see so dc5 fe4 if he doesn't
take on c5 I don't know what else you
can do so this this looks pretty normal
the night afore I've g5 maybe or even
just just Queen e2 possibly and if you
push this out for that I have 93 so we
please c6 Wow
so 93 does not really do a whole lot I
can take on f3 and play Bishop g4 maybe
or Bishop f5 so a lot of options or even
just takes an e6 maybe or Essex right
away okay but here I need to think a
little bit so Bishop g4 4 e 5 okay let's
see okay so Bishop g4 is when I'm in
here so he plays that for I'm probably
gonna go a knight III check I'm not sure
if he doesn't play off for yeah I think
I have to go 93 now okay Knight goes
King g3 which is interesting so I'll
take play Bishop f5 there spell fight
was probably a bad moves I just gave him
94 which was totally unnecessary
completely unnecessary that was that was
a bad move that was legitimately a bad
move on my part okay now I know I have
problems now I have rather serious
problems too
this is gonna be hard okay I'll play
Knight before it takes I'll take with
the rook
actually maybe I don't have problem
since since I had this night before a 95
idea that I completely did I just didn't
see that I could take with the rook on
f5 when he takes it so 92 no I think
here I have to try and break it though I
I have to break up this pawn structure
takes
so I'll just play 96 takes for burrkc a
tour Brook FC it was also there not sure
which was better I feel like maybe they
broke on I say it is better place that I
can maybe play Brooks III or maybe there
are some weakness with the F pawn here
later on Roark FC it had its trunk tubes
that gave me a bishop a seat but now I'm
gonna go over key eight anyway
g3 gonna go back with night before
Burke d2 of throwing this check here on
d3 Kingi - no no cleavage would be for
threatened both three make you one
Bishop c3 hit the rook on d2 and
everything is just kind of crumbling
here for for white and everything is
just really really crumbling so alright
let's see you next one okay I'll play
hopefully for why not six 903 against
this cotton I'm gonna save the blonde
flower I don't trust that it that I can
get away with it against this guy's he
seems a little bit too good for that
see 491 5 Oh Castle the Fox donate $5
would you answer question number 10 I
will once I see it
what does question over tank and someone
can Yuri ask it in the chat what is the
question I don't see it in the chat if
someone could uh could repost the
question since I didn't see the whole
whole question question 10 would you
rather or would you rather a going to a
rook end game up upon against Carlsen or
be going to a rook on game down a pawn
against Hanson obviously I'd rather go
into rook on game down upon against
Hanson because he's not good enough to
beat me when he's up a pawn and a rook
on game Magnus would beat me up the
Potter okay so there you go you got you
got me to answer the question the way
you wanted me to
anyways petitions looking really good
for me I have to say I'm getting uh I've
got a really nice position here night
night on c4 is great
he's got a bad pawn structure b4 b5 is
coming as well this is just a very very
pleasant position
but yeah basically I prefer also because
if I was off upon an game and it wasn't
one that was clearly winning Magnus
would almost certainly find the best
defense and make a draw
anyway this guy's got Queen Queen issues
here um it's got a lot of problems in
this position like he's he's got issues
with his queen he's got although maybe I
should have played b5 first cuz now if
he gets 95 you can swing the Queen all
the way over which I kind of I
overlooked this very slightly I mean
it's it's still very very good for me
but I overlooked at the Queen didn't
have to go to e6 here so I think I'm
gonna play e5 now and try to do
something along this long diagonal so
probably if he goes Knight c3 I'm gonna
go Queen f3 now I can take and play
Queen off three anyway I think yeah I'm
gonna take and play Queen off three
because I really want to play b5 here I
really want this move to undermine is
Queen and and just basically check me at
him on b7
question 11 would you rather become a
little champion because Carlson decided
to prepare only for the bond cloud or B
to be rescued from a raging fire by
shirtless Eric whoo I mean I would much
prefer a that's that's for sure I would
I would prefer to become world champion
because Magnus is only prepared for the
bond cloud that's a pretty easy question
so okay let's see so probably gonna get
another Kings Indian I assume maybe okay
Bishop g2 96 castles a six fish before
litora p8 c1 visualg four
d 595 probably 92 I would assume C 5 H 3
Bishop d7 I'm gonna play b5 knocks move
on was certainly b5 use this uses rook
on b8 since the work on beat is very
well placed to create threats here now
if you ever if he goes to e5 I'm gonna
have night h5 so we'll see what he's
gonna try to do so you play as b3 I
think I'll take takes us a pawn probably
I'm just gonna go work before we need to
play rugby - now again a 5 I always at
night h5 so I'm not sure my work on b2
creates any threats here
yeah g4 is a solid move now I think I
can go a 5 maybe and if he takes I take
with the bishop and c4 is weak and this
is Bishop back to e3 well such as life
play h5 probably g5 or he's gonna play
off 3 ok plays off 3 all my queen on e7
actually I probably should put my queen
on c7 so I could my queen is on c7 I
could go at queen b7 after he plays this
rook e1 or as no I can't now it's gonna
be hard to win so Knight takes b1 I'm
gonna take on g4 and IH 7 I really want
to get this Bishop to g5 if I can and I
could take I'm gonna try to keep more
pieces on the board because it denied on
b3 it you know it's better than mine on
b7 but it's also not really going
anywhere and if I can get Bishop g5
Bishop before and I'm gonna have some
chances and I need more pieces on the
board and John all if I'm gonna win this
position
it's 91 I'll play Bishop g5 about - yeah
this is kind of what I was expecting so
something like this and now I'm gonna
play Queen d8 so my bishop on g5 is
perfect tonight on h7 maybe I can
redevelop it the de Bishop is perfect
now that's a question of can I do
something over here on the Queen side
can't play for f5 what are the what are
the key ideas here so I'm gonna play
some play a 5 here why not now the
knight not b7 it's Greeks it supports
the pawn in a 5 it supports a 493 a 4x
now I'm gonna go Queen a5 also or 9595
is also interesting but hmm or Queen may
be Queen b6 here yeah I actually like
Queen b6 I was gonna go Knight a5 Bishop
f1 Queen b6 with any at night b5
blocking it
Plus Queen B one plate Queen before
maybe or takes and Knight a5 it's very
close here very very close but it's it
doesn't feel like I've quite enough to
win somehow but I'm gonna keep trying
anyway why not we should see 195 King G
2 out of 5 mister D 3 maybe I'll go f4
maybe I'll take and play push page 3
this is very very close this is very
close to being winning for me it's
probably still holding for white but
it's it's getting close to being very
very dangerous but now I can take right
free ponca stakes I can take on a3 with
chalk
well what is a - page 3 can do one
Knight f3 king of whoa King wait I think
this King g1 9:03 king of - bishop f1
yeah
I'm sorry Qing Chuang Bishop e3 e3 bit
about 2 now 3 king h1 no so I really why
wait a side we should be three there's
buff too
I have three king each one okay yeah I
guess I have to go for this it's an eye
of three hang out two takes
or oh he was supposed to go King out two
and then takes King out three Bishop d3
and then I trapped traps his knights I
think I think I dropped one of its
knights and he has declined my challenge
really okay um let's see okay so who
else thought is there anyone else okay
I'll play the Red King the Red King 30
or the right King 89 sorry I'm out 39
it's a d4 know since b3 - I basically
turned this into a 1 V 3 game so let's
it's a b6 bish should be two castles
c-46 Queen c2 seven 9351
sexy for another position that I've had
a lot actually exists this position
that steak with the seep on a CD for a
click Queen c7 so he plays rook c8 so I
take 95 probably now I can take a row 94
I think I've played both moves I forget
which one is the right move I'll take
I'll take d5 Bishop g4 so Brooke d8
probably and then rook c1 and then maybe
Bishop c8 but it anywhere it White's
quite a bit better here yeah it will see
one a5
okay so Queen c7 rook d7 so I played
Bishop f3 or I can take basically Orbis
h3 actually publish page 3 Fe for track
King h8 Black's survives yes black
survives so guess I'll take takes take
played Bishop b4 and the reason why it's
better here is even though materials
even though material is even blacks King
is open black structures a little bit
worse what white is definitely better
here is no check
grab this pawn in a 652 Queen b6 so
Queen f6 I'll just put my clean back on
e2
and now that's pretty safe so I'm just
I'm up I'm up a clean pond basically
forefront so I'm gonna just play g3
create create a square for my king d8 I
could take I'm just gonna play rook e1
though because now my King's very safe
so I want to try and create some
weaknesses here on the Queen side now
rook t2 I don't know if this is correct
but I feel like somehow with with the
three against one here on the Kings side
that should be winning I could be wrong
on that but it just it feels very very
good here b2 so I'll play rook d7 oh
wait did I just blunder wait no that
rook b6 aircraft takes out two I repeat
where he takes out two I've worked f7 or
what be something sorry yeah I know I
didn't make mistakes that's still
winning
they're too keen h3 and now I can't play
work eight wings now I'd back ranking
with rook b8 again so Chuck I'll take
the pawn in h7 I will play rook c7 and
now as you're just winning with with
three against one this is just
completely winning so work out six off
or I could have played rugby rugby it
was a better mode but this this will
work too
okay so it's one thing I'm just gonna
play probably four games I think is what
I'm gonna say play three more after this
there are two more after this one sorry
tape sticks this is all pretty standard
so far Queenie to ninety seven ninety
four of six should be to be 693 I'll
play a five if Knight of five I'll just
okay so now I place h4 interesting so
I'll play age five and probably g6 as my
next move depending I'm not sure he's
gonna play Bishop c3 or not play Bishop
c3 now I'm gonna pull Queen e7 see if
you okay so he does play d4 so I'll take
like Team B for Chuck c3 Queen e7
and now it's tricky because I mean I
want to play c5 really Knight f5
interesting very interesting that was
not a move that I was expecting so
Castle basically I think my King is
better here protecting the pawn so he
can never like put a bishop on f4 c5 g3
I'll play rook 88 5 and now if g4 I play
rook e8 rook d 3c for picking up a piece
so please King off to now I can take the
pod I don't have to but doesn't make
sense to take the pawn I think the
answer is yes it does it's just a free
pawn enough before I can play Knight e5
Knight g4 cuz that forever could
potentially trap my rook put in a bad
spot but after f4 of 95 and then Knight
g4 it's a roof d2 I'll just play I'll
play 95 all this exchange side of rooks
my king on e7 now b3 but now I can just
play Knight g4 if I want to if I want to
and I think I will
yeah Chuck cuz now as King's gonna be
cut off one way or the other so after
rookie six even though I have doubled
pawns they do count for something in the
second game
it's a rook d3 now I think I will play
with d6 and off from the exchange g3
came out seven cuz now can you - I play
ok so now it's getting better so c4
takes still doesn't quite work so with
d3 if c4 I'm gonna go eight for now b2
and play a three or Brooks III think a3
looks right because rooks see - I can go
rook d1 and then I've got complete
complete access to all the right squares
so I think first I'm gonna play rip D
for tickle and make him have to do
something about this pawn in eh for now
I'm gonna go rook d1 cuz now now g3 is a
weak I can always like swing to g1
potentially I think I'm gonna play B 1 D
2 so now I could play rook be - I don't
know if it's the right move so rook be
talking to you 3 King e6 rookie - takes
takes take skinny v g5 unclear if it's
right so I'm gonna play King e6
so now you can never go king d3 because
rook g1 so yes the key was came close to
the pawn here yeah can I go rook chew on
and now once you lose the g3 is just
completely lost
so probably he's just doing probably in
a lot of trouble here so keen for I
think I can just take King out for work
h3 rook d8 now I can go Richie - and now
that a - falls and then it's just uh
then it's just lost like King d6 king d7
wild rook c8 and maybe he takes with
Chuck
now after work g8 I can just take the
pawn rook g8 I can just take and after
what you seven it's not Chuck so I save
the tempo okay sir resigns two more to
go played b3 so we're gonna have a
repeat of this last game probably c6
Bishop e2 seven councils Queenie eight
yeah I'll play c4 because the e5 I just
taking go push b3 or he's gonna go for
it anyway interesting or sorry yeah of
course you can just play Knight g4 yeah
the obvious take 95 Queen d2 probably 90
foot 95 is coming up next
maybe I could have done it right away
also but there's no rush here
normally you reach this position with
the Queen on d8 so that's the other
thing to keep in mind I'm a little bit
used to clean Biondi 898 okay so now
here I've reached the favorable pawn
structure a5 Wow so Brooke c1
and now what is black doing exactly here
because you can't push the sea pond you
can't move your work to define it on see
it because then you hang a five if you
move your Queen to e7 there's up for
Queen d7 allows F for Queen d8 allows F
for fact blacks probably just losing a
pawn here no matter what he does so it
does play Queen d8 so now I can play a
four and queen I think I'll go for it
why not takes 23 probably night off six
I'm going to assume and I'm Bishop f3
and now how does he protect these two
pawns Uzis to lose pawns here on okay so
a key a tricky one and he still has his
to lose pawns so I'm not really sure how
is it how is he protecting them that's
the big question not really sure
actually in this position so it looks
like he's gonna lose one of them so he
plays a four okay so I'll take the free
pawn so he takes now I can take but I
think I want to take b3 so that this
pawn is still hanging on B son so he
doesn't get like some rogue a3 counter
play and so someone just asked how does
it feel to be nearing the end of your
youthful 20s I think that was the
question if I saw it correctly it popped
up across the screen I didn't didn't see
the whole question but assuming that
question was directed to me it feels
interesting I think well okay this is a
question the foss has five fostonia five
dollars thanks for streaming you're the
best online streamer well thank you so
much I appreciate I'm not sure the chest
bras would like that though anyway so
yeah so as a question goes I mean all
right so I need nearing the end of my
useful 20s um it's interesting the 20s
have been very very interesting a lot of
a lot of good times a lot of crazy
tongues a lot of bad times which has
been good learning experiences so it's a
bit of everything across the board I
think you know I I think I still feel I
still feel pretty good I don't feel like
I'm
I don't I don't feel old or anything let
me put it that way so so it so in
general yeah I feel pretty good but I
think you know the main thing is when
you're in your 20s you make a lot of
mistakes and so I think there are a lot
of a lot of good things a lot of great
memories I've had but there have been a
lot of bad things too so so there's good
there's bad that's I don't really not
that nostalgic about it I mean life goes
on so I'm just looking forward to what
the thirties hold holds for me or what's
in store tonight you for I'll take play
rook d7 somehow I've miss played this
though because here maybe I haven't cuz
now on d6 takes check King g7 I've
worked you to I go rook d8 I go rook da
King g7 and then d7 and he can't get to
d2 he can't he can't you know attack the
pawn from behind so I'm probably doing
okay here chest BAE donated $10
second-best streamer okay well I'll take
that as a compliment - okay so yeah so
this is gonna be the last game done for
for the evening for me so hopefully I
can finish it
undefeated not to jinx myself as I
almost did earlier so let's see how this
one goes
so d6 I mean normally I should have the
knight on f6 not c6 but no big deal just
keep playing play as though nothing has
happened
Castle castle play e5 d3 I'm gonna play
efore try got some kind of Kings Indian
attack fish about five probably H 5 H 4
B 4 Wow ok well I'll still fall through
h5 d 597 a 4 X 4 X 3 probably g3 play d5
try to I don't know if d5 is a good move
or not
looks very slightly suspect somehow
what I've done here this this looks a
little bit suspect so I'm just gonna
play yeah this looks very suspect I've
done something wrong here that much is
clear so I'm gonna take try to change it
up a little bit here maybe it's not
clear tape with a knight or the bishop
he's gonna take with the bishop song to
play Queen d7 for a3 I'll play rook 88
okay see one King h7 third I just hang
upon no I didn't okay I take and I've
got this b6 okay so he takes on Esau but
no that's interesting I'll take I assume
he's gonna go Knight d5 but still this
is not quite what I think you want in
this position if you're white all the
rock d8 for ceviche off to the bishop
goes to c6 it's nicely placed but then
the rook can't really put pressure on
the pawn on c7 so this is what I want I
mean I want him to go Bishop c6 because
now that my opponent c7 is safe and
there are there no real weaknesses here
it's the foster a 10-point Oh one I mean
the actual best chess player who streams
anyway thanks for the donation Foss the
best shots Larry screams all right all
right can't can't make the chest bras
angry
so anyway positions pretty positions
pretty even I think it's pretty balanced
here I'm not definitely not better I
shouldn't be worse either but again this
wants c6 it looks so pretty it's
protecting everything but he can't
attack this pawn on c7 with this this
setup with the way his Queen and Bishop
are are on this file so my goal is to
got the pawn to a4 and just like kill
him
so just twenty four twenty twenty
twenty-five twenty-six donate five
dollars
do you ever watch chess brush dreams um
occasionally I do I mean I never watched
them why not when I'm playing him
because that that's just like first of
all I think that's kind of cheating but
secondly um
it's uh it's also very distracting so so
when he's playing I mean when I'm when
I'm playing against my ion was never
actually look at what he's he's up to
in the meantime I've made a mess of the
position so I'm gonna have to like focus
a little bit here if I go clean before
work see seven Queen a three maybe or
maybe just Queen d7 yeah I've made a bit
of a mess out of this position right now
so I might actually have to focus or
whoa whoa whoa what's that
Oh cake I'm not you have to focus a bit
here so he's threatening Queen h5 so if
I take and play Queen d5 yeah this is
kind of gross oh but I do have G for
Rookie six rips e6 yeah G for the good
move rook c6 I can still take I can play
rook e6 I think this is not really how I
wanted this to go not much I can say but
I'm still I think kind of okay here okay
so he played rook see one I think Queen
g4 was actually winning but in case he's
watching my stream I didn't want to say
anything so I'll go broke up six bishops
e6 we're back in this like this little
dance here of like all the now I just
lied 94 which yeah and of course he
spots it now so I just shouldn't say
anything
clean ch3 I'm just gonna play King g7 I
might have to flag him I haven't I
haven't had to flag some in a long time
so I feel like I haven't a fly flag
anyone like him all night almost but now
I've worked for g5 takes takes I'm gonna
play g5 I guess or an ER no I can just
retreat my King g5 Bishop g7 d5 that's a
free Knight d6 Queen in five takes I can
play Queen c7 right yes I can and he'll
take he'll play Bishop d5 but he's gonna
lose a bunch of pawns now this probably
still is a draw oddly enough maybe with
the three versus one but but I'm
definitely not gonna give them a draw
here
and anyway yeah okay who that was huh
that was a tough last game actually um
so anyway I guess that means I actually
won every game tonight that was not what
I that's pretty surprising um but anyway
yeah so I mean I I hope you guys enjoyed
the stream
I think I actually think I heard another
donation come in test twenty four twenty
five six seven eight five dollars when
did you decide to retire the legendary
Capilano bridge who is the I can't see
the I can't see the end of the question
I assume I mean who's the best now yeah
so to answer that question I um I
stopped playing on ICC probably about
three years ago it just seems like most
of the most of the bus players have been
migrating towards chess calm in general
over the past couple of years so yeah so
I was probably 2014 when I stopped using
the account as far as who's the best now
I'm I don't know I haven't actually
looked closely at who's still playing on
on ICC but if I had to take a guess
probably like Chris Chuck or ma'am you
are off since I think they're both still
playing on there one of those two but
yeah so anyway yeah so I hope you guys
enjoyed the stream I think I'll probably
be back on Saturday as my guess Saturday
in the afternoon I'm gonna say something
like noon noon or 1:00 1:00 p.m.
sometime around then assume there's not
a Yankees game that is if there's no
Yankees game if they win Game six
tomorrow then everything will kind of
get back to normal but I'm gonna say
that most likely I'll be be around on
Saturday afternoon so that's when I'm
gonna do my next stream as I said unless
the Yankees when Eric and unless the
Yankees lose tomorrow night in which
case it might be Sunday it'll be
something slightly different but that's
not at any rate so yeah so I hope you
guys enjoyed the stream
and I'll be back soon so have a good
evening everyone
adios